The joe rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
Damn,
I forgot to tweet that I was doing this.
Should I tweet it?
Tweet it while I'm talking about it
while we're talking about the fleshlight.
What's this?
What we do?
We'll have an extended little conversation
about the flashlight while I tweak
this.
Here we go.
Jokes.
You have a butthole on here that that's
been used as a prop since we started
getting sponsored by the flashlight.
And so many comics fingers
are so dirty and nasty.
Now the Butthole,
it looks like a white really bad.
Yeah,
it does look like a dirty
butthole and it slept a weird,
like sort of like a really,
uh,
like not a black person,
but like a really dark islander.
Yeah.
When they have you ever see like,
like,
like girls from like the
Filipino Hawaiian girls asshole.
They have,
there's a certain darkness
to the vagina area.
Yeah.
What's that all about?
It's just,
you know,
just like some people's
butts are normal color,
some people just are purple.
But do you think there's some
evolutionary reason to have your,
uh,
your,
your butthole in your vagina?
Lips darker.
Yeah,
because there's not supposed to fuck it.
You know that there's a
dangerous bitches are better.
The dark,
the sweeter the juice.
Right,
right.
Isn't that what the theory behind that
shit is always fear of a white planet?
What the fuck are we talking about?
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight and
you can get 15% off the number one sex
toy and they have like Zombie flashlights.
Now case you can fuck
a mouth of a vampire.
I think.
Oh No,
it's even worse now.
Now it looks like there's like,
it's been damaged in a car
accident and it's just like,
it looks like or feels like it's decaying.
Oh,
what the fuck is wrong with people?
Is that like a novelty thing?
I think is,
yeah,
the holidays and shit.
And you know,
there's a lot of horror fans.
Yeah.
Gas,
but to fuck it,
it's one thing.
Maybe it's a novelty one.
Maybe it's like a car that you don't
drive because it's a special edition
corvette or some shit.
So just put it in your garage
and hope it's an investment.
We're also brought to you by on it,
O,
n n I t.com.
Makers of Alpha brain.
Alpha brain is a cognitive,
some enhancing.
I always fuck this up.
It's just the pills are
supposed to make you smart.
And I see I don't have
anything planned out.
We never like sat down and said,
well this is what we'll
say about Alpha brain.
So I say,
oh,
it's a cognitive enhancing
something or another.
It's fucking real good
for making you fuck man.
Want to feel pretty clear when I'm on it.
But how ironic that when you
start talking about it this,
this,
for some reason this
subject makes people mad.
This bringing up this Alpha brain thing.
So I want to say this,
please don't buy it please.
I want,
this is what I want you to do.
I want you to try find what the
ingredients are and Alpha brain,
look it up online and
on a.com it's available.
Take the exact ingredients of some bulk
stuff that you can buy for much cheaper
than what we did when we put all this
together in like sort of a one-stops
shopping sort of a situation.
Go buy that stuff,
please,
please buy it and just try it.
And I know people have positive results.
I've talked to people with it.
Some people don't.
Some people,
and I don't know whether
that's a subjective thing,
I don't know whether or not they,
they,
they can't differentiate
between a good and a bad day,
whether it just doesn't work on them.
Where everybody's biologically different.
I mean some people can't eat peanuts.
One peanut no fucking die.
Everyone's system is different.
For me,
the shit works.
I'm not lying to you.
Please stop saying I am.
Stop sending me mean tweets.
It's annoying.
You don't have to buy it.
I'm not forcing you to.
But to tell me that I'm not
experiencing positive results from it.
And then all these other people that
are taking it in and talking to me about
all the great results.
Just to say that we're not selling,
saying,
telling the truth is just insulting and
it's stupid and it doesn't make sense.
You fuckhead you don't
know what I'm feeling.
And by the way,
it's not the placebo effect because
you could have fucking incredible vivid
dreams and their vivid dreams to me.
I don't remember ever
having dreams like this for,
I started taking this shit.
I don't even know if it's more vivid.
I think you just,
it like,
I remember it more like you
usually wake up and you forget it.
Now I can remember true.
I know.
Yeah.
How would I know if I don't remember him?
Whether or not there were vivid.
Yeah,
but that to me is like stats,
some fucking tangible proof,
man.
And even if it is a placebo,
I don't think it is.
But even if it was,
I liked placebos given give me to me,
giving me a trick me,
trick me with your pet rock trick me.
I'm in this for results.
If you can give me some shit that cures
cancer for some fucking crazy reason.
But meanwhile I was just a sugar pill.
Give it to me,
give it to me.
They should sell pills and placebo
in it and just call it placebo.
I'm not convinced that we have a
handle on how the human brain works.
By the way,
we're going to talk to
David Lipton about this.
He's going to actually come on the
podcast and talk to us about it,
uh,
about this subject.
So we're,
we're setting that up and he's a way
smarter than us on all these subjects.
The fucking Joe Rogan experience is
ready to drop on going old school.
It's just me and Brian today.
Oh,
robotics.
[inaudible]
Steve Jobs.
Feminine essence from beyond the grave.
That's what that is.
That's what it seems like.
We were just talking about the apple TV
the other day in New York Times today.
They have apple TV with Siri.
Uh,
2013.
They think it's going to be,
that's all rumor right now though,
right?
That's crazy though.
We were just talking about what,
two days ago?
Well,
didn't we read about it?
No,
I'm just,
I,
I is it just speculation did something
in his biography about he's figured out
the TV and then I just like,
Hey Siri,
TV seems like it would make it so,
so yeah.
So you read the whole biography already?
No,
no.
I'm still reading it right now.
It's a lot of people are angry with him.
A lot of people are saying because
the cup to the fleshlight in case you
wondered what was a gentleman
that's put that away,
put that away.
A lot of people like going,
God,
he's such a Douche bag.
Like he like he accomplished so much.
Yeah.
I had this brilliant vision.
He followed through and
create the greatest computers,
known demand.
But everybody just keeps
saying he's a douchebag.
Well,
you have to be true though.
I thought you didn't see this
is what really bothers me.
Right.
Because I always saw him.
I will.
This guy's fucking cool.
He's like a Buddhist.
He's obviously really intelligent.
He's so beloved.
I mean,
how is there ever been a more beloved CEO?
that guy was a God damn rock star.
Steve Jobs would get out on that stage
and those geeks would freak the fuck out.
There was like,
he's here,
he's leading us.
It's like he was leading a movement.
It wasn't just like he's a
CEO of a technology company.
He was a part of this apple movement.
And also fueled by that sort of
underdog thing that everybody loves.
People love being an underdog man.
They love being in the
fucking unknown band,
you know?
Or knowing about the unknown band and
going to see them before they broke before
they go mainstream.
People love like small things against
the fucking oppressive Microsoft regime.
Fuck you windows.
I'll never,
why windows?
I'll fucking Mac till I die.
There's something weird about that.
And there's some Unix dorks that do that
right now and Linux dorks and you know,
so I think it was part of that,
that he would all of a sudden made this,
this little underdog successful and it
was blossoming in front of everybody's
eyes.
So you get to tell your friends,
oh yeah,
fucking Max are up 2% this week.
You know,
and like,
you know the number one stock and
the stock market and people would,
it would,
it was like really like you're
rooting for the fucking buffalo bills.
You know,
it might as well have been some
baseball team that you were,
you were on.
It wasn't just this operating system
thing and this guy was like a fucking hero
man.
It was like a heroin,
a sitcom or,
or a a TV show rather,
you know,
like he came along and all of a sudden
he's leading these people on this fucking
[inaudible] episode adventure where he
keeps bringing you cooler and Cooler
Shit,
you know,
and you,
you,
you know,
as long as you,
I'm a Mac person,
I'm down with Mac and
then everybody sort of,
you know,
you either became macro PC but if
you are Mac boy that's your guy.
You know,
like him being called an asshole
and hard to work with and stuff.
He probably had half to be,
he had a vision and no one else is
understanding what he's thinking,
but he has to make sure it goes through
to like what he's thinking in his head
on paper to a product.
And there's people probably
putting their 2 cents and like,
no,
we shouldn't do that.
And it probably was like he
was a controlling aspect,
but you know what?
Those all those people right now,
they all fucking get it.
You know,
like the iPhone probably was weird when
he first was trying to talk about it.
You know,
it's all,
it's like,
look at all the different people working
in all the various companies and just
think about this.
How much of yourself are you really,
truly willing to give further
your company's success?
How much of yourself do you and how much,
how intelligent are you truly?
How well read are you?
How introspective or you,
how objective are you?
Are you really honest
about your own ideas?
Are you immersed in your ego?
And if you don't have a
handle on all of those things,
if you don't like have answers
to all of those questions.
A guy like Steve jobs comes along and
he can do some shit that you can't do.
Okay.
Because that guy will,
he will work til he drops.
He's super fucking smart.
He's done LSD.
He said it was like most
important things of his life,
you know.
I mean he had some,
you know,
he had some flaws for sure,
but he was also this,
you know,
it's really like a cliche,
the star that shines twice as bright,
lasts half as long.
But it really almost is.
I mean,
I can't say that he
caused his own disease.
Right.
But I can't think that it helps to work
like a fucking demon to wear like a man
possessed to live the company he worked
on the day he died in the hospital room,
he was finishing off a certain product,
which some are saying the iPhone
five some are saying to it,
the Apple TV and that he
did on the day he died.
That's so crazy.
I guess he just figured,
fuck it.
I'll just ride this bitch
right into the beach.
Yeah.
Amazing.
But what an impact.
You need to think about like the impact
that that guy had on all the different,
different human beings
who enjoyed his products,
us included.
You know,
we're both Mac Dorks,
you know,
I've considered pcs.
I fuck around with them a little bit.
They're beautiful too.
They have great operating system.
It's way better than the
old operating systems,
but God damn it.
If I don't know a million
people with viruses,
God damn,
if,
I don't know everybody I talked to,
he's got some new thing where they went
to a porn site and now every time they
turn in their fucking computer,
they see dicks.
You know,
it's just,
I mean,
that happens all the time.
Get a bigger dick,
got a bigger Dick and get a bigger dick.
Like God damn it.
You fuck like Dylan infect you
with a big Dick Commercial?
Well,
it's kind of like your message board.
Anytime somebody gets pink or anything.
And I like putting the pink room.
If they're really bad,
used to change talktalk's cars,
which is the worst disease
Dick we could find on.
I actually asked people to stop
doing that because it got obsessive.
I don't want to call anybody out or what.
The one guy did it,
he admitted it was like,
that's me.
I'm like,
dude,
I'm gonna fucking cocktails.
Have you given out?
He'd give it out like hundreds
of them and it's so homophobic.
I used to,
but you know,
just to start gesture story,
I don't know if you're
going to post anymore,
but he was one that I gave a cocktail
or two and he was really a funny photo
because the Dick was so small and what
I never told anybody is that every day I
made a little bit smaller,
a little bit smaller,
a little bit smarter.
I told there was no dick and no one ever,
never noticed.
It takes the most ridiculous dedication.
Why did you do that?
I don't know because the days of this,
I think it was like probably seven days,
but it was,
he was,
he was so upset because I think it
was one of the first cocktail hours.
He was so upset that,
that he got such a horrible Dick.
Okay,
it's so small.
What the fuck dude?
And that is rude to make
people post with an Avatar,
someone's deck.
But some of those guys are dicks.
Right.
You know,
it's like there's no better way to
discourage douchey behavior than to punish
people for it.
And it's not like it's a real punishment.
So fucking message board.
You don't have to be there.
You know,
you don't want to be there
and I'll stop you there.
But for some people,
man,
you put him in that pink room and
they go fucking ballistic on you.
It's fascinating.
It's fascinating to watch.
I mean the,
the,
the special ed room is really
a fascinating experiment
because it's like the
Stanford prison studies that they did,
you know,
when they like students like pretend
to be prison guards and then other
students,
they had to cut though short
because people get crazy.
Right.
You know,
they got,
they got nutty and they started behaving
as if it was like a real prison.
They've got like really creepy.
They had to like cut the experiments.
Sure.
And it wasn't very many days and it was
like seven days or something like that.
I'd have to re reread it over and over
again to really get a handle on it.
But the idea that you would tell
them that can only post in one form,
now all of a sudden it's like prison.
It's really weird.
It's like the fucking trapped in here.
Meanwhile,
you're on the Internet.
Every,
everyone on the board can read it,
they can read it.
It's just like what's been with what we
decided is we're going to have to forums
and one form is essentially uncensored
except for I don't all out autoplays or
you can't have autoplays,
you can't trick people.
I can't Rick Roll people,
you know,
nothing stupid like that,
then we'll just ban you.
But other than that,
you can pretty much do whatever
the fuck you want unless you're,
you know,
if someone tunes in though and finds out
that you're a super content there and
then you're like,
what does this guy even to here for,
what's the point?
And then there'll be,
we'll just ban you.
But I find myself hanging out more in a
special ed room than the regular form.
Like I go only to the podcast foreign.
And then once in a while,
good at Special Ed.
Like I don't even go to the regular form.
I probably gone twice in the last year.
Um,
I just started going into the Special
Ed Forum recently and checking,
cause some guys actually
will post some cool shit.
They're just assholes.
You know,
they'll post some cool shit,
but then they'll get online
and call somebody a nigger
or call somebody a faggot
and you're like,
okay,
what the fuck?
Come on man,
what are you doing?
There's not a need for this.
This is stupid.
This is like,
you know,
especially when a lot
of times it's like no,
no point to escalating.
Like people would just
escalate for no reason.
You know?
And I wonder how he's,
if it's like the name shit talking one
on one because then we change it for a
little while.
We change it.
I did.
I changed it for a short period of time,
but I don't remember what I called it.
What theme are you on?
Are you on the blue or the black?
I like the blue.
Yeah,
I'm on the black.
I went back to the black and I think
in the black it used to be on a sign.
Is that shit talking one
on one and then that's it.
That was the art drawing.
I think it was like an old drive through
movie movie theater or something.
I can't remember for what people don't
know what the fuck we're talking about.
There's you,
when you click on the,
there's like a wink at the pot of money
somewhere in the message board that
allows you to choose from
different styles of message board.
It's either black with white
font or blue with black font.
Right?
Like a really light blue that
a lot of people think is gay.
But I like it.
No I'm usually on that.
But I switched back to black.
I like it because it's
reminds me of sunny skies,
blue skies,
I like blue skies,
they make me happy.
So I look at that and
I like the way it is.
I think there's a direct correlation
between like looking at like certain dark
dark colors and having dark thoughts.
You know,
I think there is a
correlation between those two.
You know,
I think maybe the message board would
be less country if people just use the
blue.
Have you ever,
have you ever owned a house or an
apartment that just had like really bright
yellow walls?
I like like bright light,
like kitchen,
like bright yellow maybe.
It's so nice.
You always feel happy and
clean when you're in it.
Really?
Yeah.
Try it out.
Try it.
Find a room and just
paint it bright yellow.
You'll be surprised.
It's weird.
What the fuck is that all about?
It's just exactly what you're saying.
It's just one of those colors.
It makes you feel good.
Yeah.
The Sun obviously.
Right.
And Blue Sky yellow the sun.
Yeah,
that totally makes sense.
You know?
That's what I mean when you talk about
people that live in places like Seattle
where it rains constantly.
What's the number one complaint?
They don't get sun.
They get depressed and that's why
so many of them commit suicide.
You know what I mean?
That's like a big issue,
man.
It's really a vitamin
D deficiency as well.
Apparently your brain,
your body makes vitamin D
while you're in the sun,
like while you're in the sun,
your body is producing a vitamin.
It's pretty interesting,
you know?
And uh,
that only happens in your body like that.
You know you could eat it and you
can supplement it in pill form,
but you only get it make your body only
makes it if you're in the sunlight that
it's really,
really kind of fucking interesting.
You need it,
you know,
it's like important to health.
Before I moved to California,
I lived in his house and every
room was a different color.
Like my office was dark,
Crimson Red and my kitchen
one is bright yellow,
exact etc. But it's weird.
Each room did have like a certain
feel to it when you were in it.
Like the bedroom was black Wallace,
which I thought was the worst idea
ever and that was just horrible.
Yeah,
it's horrible looking at the
comedy store and sleeping.
That's someone who wants to fuck in the
dark if you want to fucking dark walls.
Just darkness.
Yeah.
That's some golf sharing.
Some people want to fuck
with the lights out,
you know?
That's weird.
You know?
Have you ever be able to check
and she said turn the lights out?
No,
I kind of like it.
Damn.
I don't like it bright though.
I don't like it.
You know,
like it was just like
super bright gynecological.
That's what I like it.
I like a like a showroom,
like a car showroom.
Oh Wow.
See,
I think if I manscaped
war I wouldn't mind it,
but I feel like it's
going to kill the deal.
It probably will.
Probably will.
Did you see the photo of Steven Tyler?
Uh,
we,
we talked about like how I almost
slipped and killed myself in the bathtub.
He did it at a hotel room and he
slipped and fell and he said that,
you know,
it was just,
he,
you know,
he slipped nothing to it and he,
the photo of him,
he like knocked teeth out.
He's got a black eye.
I don't know if you can
see this right here,
but it fucked him up,
man.
That's just from taking a bath
and accidentally slipping.
Whoa.
That is nuts.
That picture is fucking nuts,
man.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Well he got jacked,
clumsy.
Fuck.
Have you ever done it though?
It'd be just like slimy feed
or almost fallen backwards,
which is the most terrifying thing,
which is,
you know,
if you fall and hit the back of your head,
that's how people die.
If you're sloppy,
you're tired,
you know,
whatever,
you're not really 100% paying attention,
you know,
Shit.
You could,
you,
you can get slippery.
Bathtubs are fucking dangerous as shit.
I mean,
uh,
especially the old ones,
those cast iron ones.
You know,
if you have an old place
and you have a old tub,
those old tubs were fucking iron dude.
I mean,
it's like fallen.
Think about falling
backwards and hitting iron.
That's essentially
like getting hit in the head by the world.
You know,
that's what it's like.
The world came down on you and
hit you and that's what it's like.
It's like,
fuck man,
you get jacked.
That's like really dangerous.
If you ever watched those fights
where people get in street fights,
a lot of videos on youtube
and guys get knocked out.
And what's terrifying is
when they get knocked out,
they fall back in their head,
hits the concrete.
Whoa.
That's scary,
dude.
I've seen that happen in real life.
It is terrifying.
It's like a bowling ball
dropping on the guards.
Terrified.
So dangerous to your head.
Just Bonk,
just skull.
And who knows what the fuck
is going on inside that skull?
How much bleeding there is,
how much swelling there is.
I mean your brain,
it's just jam packed.
That one dude's Jack from getting hit
in the head and they're saying that he's
at might have brain damage that the vet,
they got shot at the occupy Oakland.
You how fucked is that man?
Cops are targeting the
fucking people throwing these,
these uh,
tear gas canisters out on that explode.
Then flash grenades.
There's video of this
guy laying on the ground.
Injured people went up to try
to help him and they shoot them.
No,
no.
They throw the grenade at them.
Flash bomb.
Athema tear gas bomb after,
you know,
they blow up and they,
if they hit you in the fucking
head while they're exploding,
like you can get jacked.
But it's just so sad to see these
cops are targeting these people.
It's like,
man,
what is this fucking Chicago in
the 60s what the fuck is this?
You know what I mean?
I can't believe that
these are our citizens,
that these cops are our friends
and our neighbors and our citizens.
These occupy people
aren't hurting anybody.
Man.
Your job is to serve and protect and
you don't need to protect anybody from
these people.
These people are nonviolent.
They're not hurting anybody
to serve and protect.
What part of that is throw a
fucking grenade at someone's head.
Especially some guy who did two tours,
a fucking duty,
two tours of duty overseas.
He comes back and he's in
critical condition from the
fellow citizen of fellow
American throwing a fucking Flashman
had out a guy who's paid by this
motherfucker's tax dollars.
That's a sad,
sad statement,
man.
It's sad that people are jumping up
and down about this and the politicians
aren't fucking condemning this and that
people aren't all over the news saying,
this can never happen again and we need
to fucking sit down with these cops and
have a long conversation as to
what your fucking job entails.
Your job entails helping people out,
man,
that's what you're here for.
You,
our citizens that have extra power and
we give you that extra power so that you
make things nicer.
You're not making things nicer by throwing
flash grenades on fucking veterans.
That's not making anything nicer.
And that's the only reason to have cops.
The only reason I have comps is
to keep the Douche bags down,
to keep them away from the nice people
and then help the nice people in the nice
people in trouble.
That's it.
And when the nice people get angry
because the bags are fucking robbing them,
you don't throw grenades at them.
You're fucking cunts.
I can't believe it happened
in California also.
There's no joke,
bro.
Yeah,
but like New York City it perfect example,
the the governor or whatever said,
hey,
you know,
get rid of all these protestors
in a certain area of New York.
And the cops were like,
no,
we're not.
They're not doing anything bad.
We're not doing this.
I don't think you ever been to Oakland.
Yeah,
I know.
But still,
it's no joke.
You need to go and hang out
in Oakland for a little while.
Oh,
next time I needed an abortion,
I'll go there.
Get abortions in La still.
I know want abortions
are illegal in the state.
Oakland was still have a voice.
Right?
You'll be able to go there.
Yeah,
but I so like in New York there,
what was that too?
Short dog.
Who is the,
the the,
the pimp.
Goddammit.
Short dog.
What's his name?
Too Short.
Too Short,
that guy show white am I,
I'm like Chevy Chase white in a movie
when I'm driving a station wagon.
And that's how white I am.
Short guy's name was,
you know,
short lag.
What's his name?
Too Short,
too short is from Oakland,
you know,
and he's always talking about Oakland.
I Tom McCormick lives in Oakland now.
Oakland is the weirdest
combination of like gangsters.
Hi Mccormick lives.
Yup.
Gangsters and hippies and like,
and and weed people.
They call it Oaksterdam.
You know,
they have like Oaksterdam University,
like we don't even know the level of
medical weed that the state has reached.
The reason why all these
people are clamoring,
and apparently this was just released,
that it wasn't Obama's idea to go after
these medical marijuana dispensaries,
right.
It was the attorney general or
the whoever the fuck gets to was,
it was,
it was.
It was somebody in California,
one of the rare people in the Senate,
or we're talking,
we're talking so nuts.
I said,
I didn't even know the set it is.
I know what that means.
That's like some of them.
I found it on Twitter,
so I'll,
I'll retweet it or something like that.
But what it is a,
what essentially they're saying is that
Obama is not respected enough by these
people,
for them to follow his lead.
What he said when he was in office was
that he wants to only attack or only go
after the people that are violating
both federal and state law.
Marijuana is illegal
across the board federally.
So as long as they were
following state law,
he would leave them alone.
And the state law,
you know,
it's fucking,
it's pretty tricky because it's
really supposed to be nonprofit.
You know?
I don't,
I don't think you're supposed to be able
to make millions of dollars and a lot
of these guys are just fucking balling
and I support it 100% but I'm just
stating the facts.
The real true facts is that we don't
even know the level of medical marijuana
that's hit like California.
Our area is really like on the outskirts.
The real hive of it is
in northern California.
The real hive of it is an Oakland where
they're having classes where they're
teaching people how to
fucking set grow ops up there.
Like people are signing up
for classes and it's like,
you know,
they'd given degrees on
how to fucking grow weed.
It's really fascinating shit.
They're taking it to the next level.
They're teaching people how to do it.
They have these big,
and so the government obviously
feels threatened by this,
this,
this along
with this whole occupy
Wall Street movement.
And Pete when when you
get hippies with money,
shit gets dangerous as fuck cause
you got to a place like Oaksterdam,
you place like it just,
let's say there was a place they're
going to open up in boulder,
I think it was like 30,000 square feet.
It was three stories.
I don't know if it ever opened,
but that was like the people,
people who are proven it,
people in boulder like fine bringing
in just not going to bother us.
And when they were doing that,
people are thinking how much money can
I place like this bring in millions of
dollars,
millions and millions and millions.
It could be incredible amounts of money
if you really stop and think about it.
If they have just radical
open commerce on marijuana,
how many people are going to
grow their own fucking shit?
Not me.
I'm not,
I don't have that kind of time.
Dude,
I can't be watering plants.
Okay.
I got kids,
I got shit to do.
I've got hobbies.
I don't want to water plants.
It might be interesting if I
decided to take it on as a hobby.
But if it,
if I could just go down the
street and buy weed at the store,
if I can go to seven 11 and buy some weed,
cause that's how it should,
it could be.
It really could be like that.
And when that happens,
those places,
those places that like those
medical marijuana places or whoever,
there's decides to open up like
a big flashy emporium of weed,
they can become very wealthy
and then they become,
they can become very powerful.
When someone becomes wealthy,
they become powerful.
And as they're seeing
people accumulate wealth,
they're trying to stop it and then not
trying to stop because they're protecting
anybody.
They're not protecting any civilians.
You know,
by stopping these people
from making money.
If these people are making
money and paying taxes on it,
you should be happy they're
contributing to the economy.
This is good.
This is not bad.
We need to change the law.
You don't need to make it so it's legally,
it's either legal or it's not illegal.
It's legal to sell it to people.
It should be illegal to
make money off of it.
You're telling me that marijuana
can't make money off of it,
even though it's legal as a drug.
But they can make money off of opium.
They can make money off of heroin,
they can make money off of cocaine and
fucking oxycontin's and nicotine and
alcohol.
They can make money off that,
but they can't make money off week.
Fuck you.
This is an injust law.
This is an injust law and it's nonsense.
And the reason why is because
they're scared of hippies with money,
hippies with money or dangerous as fuck.
Man.
If you've got a bunch of people,
idealists who really,
truly want to change the world and all
of a sudden their richest fuck dude,
things can get slippery,
things can,
it's slippery when we people
join together and say,
you've got to recognize the weed dollar.
All right cause there's a stoner dollar
out there and it's you and it's me and
it's a lot of other fucking people and
we buy shit and we pay shit and we pay
our taxes and we contribute to
society and we're not bad people.
And at a certain point in time,
you're going to have to
respect that stoner dollar.
Cause if you don't,
that Shit's going to come back and bite
you in the ass because there's too many
of us now.
There's too many of us and
now because of the Internet,
just like occupy Wall Street,
just like anonymous.
We're United,
we're all United.
Likeminded people are United now.
People who exchange ideas and evolve
their own ideas on the internet and share,
share a viewpoint with each
other and learn from each other.
We're United now.
This is a different time,
man.
You can't just control people like you
used to be able to control people in the
60s and the 70s we couldn't
talk to each other.
We had a huddle in our fucking homes
at night listening to the radio,
hoping everything was going to be okay.
Well this isn't that day man.
These cops that are staging these fucking
fake shootings at schools so they can
check the kids for drugs.
You know,
you're just horse for some pharmaceutical
company from some giant conglomerate
and the only reason you're doing that,
it's because the weed
dollar hasn't hit you yet.
Once the weed dollar hits you,
you're going to shut the fuck up.
You're going to have to shut the fuck
up because the weed people are going to
help the cops that weed
people are going to promote,
you know,
a,
a good relationship with
the police officers.
They'll contribute just like,
you know,
these fucking,
these giant banks are contributing to
occupy Wall Street down in Wall Street.
These banks for four point $6 million
was donated to the New York police
department so that they can fucking
like look out for all these assholes.
These,
these are rich fucking
money thieving cunts.
Think about that,
you know,
wrap wrap,
wrap your head around that.
When the we dollars starts doing that,
two things are gonna change.
Everyone's going to have to look at it
that way and they're so terrified of
that.
That is a,
that's something that really
could truly change the world.
People who are trippers,
who have money trippers who
have money and philanthropy,
philanthropic ideas and the
ambition to follow through on them.
And the pharmaceutical companies
are terrified of that shit.
Politicians are terrified of that shit,
whether they admit it or not,
they're terrified of that shit on top of
the fact that you have to say you don't
like drugs because everybody thinks about
the children and it's saying you like
drugs is just too controversial
to many people are ignorant.
They don't get it.
So it's like saying you don't like tools.
To me it's like I don't want tools.
We're going to just leave
things the way they are.
Yay.
Do you think it's a certain age group
that's just going to die off though
eventually and then it's going to be more
accepted and say like 10 to 20 years?
You know why?
Yes.
And you know why?
Because of this,
because of things like this podcast,
because of the Twitter,
because of Facebook,
because of,
you know,
Mark Marin's Blah or a podcast or a should
fears podcast to all the death squad
pod,
all that free talking people,
people who are allowed because of this
sort of a format to express themselves in
a way uncensored that millions
of people you can get.
I mean you good or bad,
you can make a youtube video like that
video of the lady sitting on the toilet
there were watching the other day,
terrible,
but 38 million eyes have seen that man.
38 million people have seen that.
That's incredible.
I mean that's amazing
that you can do that.
Now.
There was,
there's never been a time in human history
where you could do anything that can
almost immediately be recognizing and
seen by so many people through Twitter,
through Facebook,
through blogs and podcasts.
And this is the shit
that's changing the world,
man.
This is what's changing the world.
Free Open communication.
They,
this is where the
government truly fucked up.
It's not what drugs.
Cause the problem with free
open communication is we go,
why not drugs?
If it was just drugs and we didn't
have free open communication and the,
the reality is this is not much you can
do if you can't communicate with each
other.
It's hard to organize things.
It's hard to get a movement going.
It's hard.
You know,
you have to have a person
who's a leader and that person
gets arrested.
You can never have the type of situation
right now the occupy Wall Street,
this hive mind situation,
this exists solely because of the
internet and it never existed before.
This is where there's a total different
sort of revolution going on right now.
And essentially what's happening is
we're setting the stage for the next
generation in a big,
big,
big way because the next generation is
not going to be these cops throwing flash
grenades anymore.
It's going to be cops that have to
realize that to be a police officer,
you're just,
another one of us were just,
you're just one of us that we'd give a
weapon so that you protect people and
when you stop doing nice things
and you start being a problem,
you can't be a company more.
It's not,
there's no union thing.
There's no,
we got our rights and we go to fucking
labor thing and you go to sit down with a
mediator.
No,
no,
you can't do that.
You can't be that.
That's not what a police officer is.
That's not a bank or can't steal from you.
You can't charge 30% entrance.
You fuck heads.
You can't not have the money when the
shit hits the fan because you've invested
it shittily you know there's these things.
Things cannot be variables and that is,
the stage is being set right now.
That's the stage is being
set in our generation.
Our generation is setting the
stage for the next generation,
the generation that is going to grow up
and evolve from birth to death with the
Internet.
That's a different generation than us.
You know,
you and I are from the,
we're we're dinosaurs,
man.
Where we were around when
answering machines where the,
the shit you're going to be that there's
probably going to the next generation,
the generation to come.
It's probably going to get to the point
where it's something like there's going
to be a cat as a president
or something like that.
You know,
like we nominated frisky over here and
he somehow one because why not frisky
doesn't have any skeletons in his closet.
Know first.
He's never,
you know,
and he's just the face of a nation,
he's not really doing any of that.
Wouldn't work the fuck.
Might as well have the face be cute.
It could be Dora,
Dora the explorer can be our president.
You know,
Dora the explorer or Sarah Pailin.
Who would make the better choices?
Dora at least would look
at the screen and go,
what are you guys think?
Yeah,
we're going to send
drones in the Pakistan.
We don't need to waste soldiers.
We can shoot them from the air.
That's how Dora the explorer
would be the president.
Really?
Sarah Palin's you to tell your pussy.
I bet you she's had a bunch of kids.
Man,
that thing's probably a wreck Dora,
but I bet she gives up the ass.
Did you?
I see that monks,
I showed you the shots of Jack Daniels.
A little cocaine in her.
Which Lindsay Lohan Mugshot.
Would you fuck?
Yeah.
Lindsay Lohan got arrested again
and her dad got arrested again.
God Damn.
If you had to pick one though,
which one would it be?
Oh,
fuck off him.
I was drunk.
I know.
No one.
You have to choose one.
I would probably go with the one,
uh,
second to the right.
I would go with the far right.
The palest one.
Oh,
the scary one.
I think she looks hot and
ready to go in that picture.
She looks,
it's fascinating that that was
unsear that I tweeted about this.
That was on CNN front fucking page news
about him getting arrested and I'm like,
really?
If it's,
is it on your front page,
your website?
Some guy who's a shitty dad got arrested.
Michael Lohan,
really?
You Care,
you care.
You fucking really care.
Why are you showing me this?
You Dragon the dragon characters
into my plot that I don't need.
You don't need them in my,
my show.
Yeah.
And the only reason I like
about my life then I'm watching.
Don't you think Lindsay Lohan would be
the perfect person to date to try to
change?
Really?
No.
It doesn't seem like I can change you.
I can make,
I can get you out of all of this.
Can't change.
You can't change your vigil.
I mean,
if you were on the same level,
no.
You'd have to be really,
really rich man.
How many people were as Rich's
Lindsey fucking Lohan Richie's doing.
You're crazy.
Boy.
Listen man,
they're offering her $1 million.
Fleshlight is to make a mold
out of her box slash light off.
So now our boys.
Yes,
please.
So we could have Lindsay Lohan on.
Yeah,
we'll talk about it.
She won't come on this podcast.
She couldn't come here.
We'd have to bring it to your
place to say I was a lesbian.
This is Rebecca.
Doesn't want that.
Skank hang around here.
But uh,
I think she's still rich,
man.
I think she's,
unless she's just been horribly mismanaged
court costs though that she's been
going through so much.
Coke came probably maybe her court
problems aren't like murder or shit.
They're like really drains you financially
because you have to establish some
sort of a case.
It's for getting in trouble for shit.
There's really not much court work.
I mean,
not much legal work they can do
to try to squeeze her out of it.
She's a fucking coke
ad and she gets drunk.
She gets fucked up.
She,
she,
she likes to party man.
And we said this before,
she's a 20 whatever the fuck she is.
25 2050 she's died.
I think she should really,
I think she's just find out how will it,
is Lindsey alone?
I would say she's 23 really 20 yeah.
22 or 2125
Michael Lohan,
would you fuck,
she's 25 she's 25 I'm right.
So 25 and she looks like 25 in dog years.
That's just age and hard.
Whatever.
I,
she looks,
she does look hot,
but so does Jimmy Moore and she's
like 48 and I was shit lately.
Let me show you a photo
being nice dark photos over.
I don't want to see it.
I don't want to see it all go away.
What happened?
How did she,
how did she just lost
her grip on the magic?
I don't know.
She couldn't find the
little girl to sing too.
I think it's like tangled
with the magic hair.
I don't know.
I don't know what the rumor is.
That was that there'd be more joke.
What the rumor is?
What?
What'd you say?
Never.
Nothing.
Alright.
You've got a photo over
with she looks back.
Hold on.
I'm looking at,
I'm trying to find it.
Google to me more looking bad.
Me More arms or arms.
Yeah,
I think we talked about it on a podcast.
So already there's this horrible
photo that was at recently.
Um,
it's like when people were like
shitting on Megan Fox thumbs,
they'll look luminar
thumbs up or thumbs like,
bitch,
what are you talking about?
That's one of the hightest women that's
ever walked the face of the planet.
And you're,
you're looking at her thumbs.
You could,
she could chop those fucking thumbs off
machetes and replaced them with eagle
cause it could be an
eagles talent on each hand.
And I wouldn't mind,
I feel a little weird.
Here's what,
grabbing my deck with an Eagle
Talon for a thumb though.
I guess it's not odd.
I found it,
but it gets,
it's not all.
It's actually that she has,
she's anorexic looking like she like it.
You're starting to be able to
see like how creepy her arms are.
Uh,
there's another shot that her hand,
I think it's
this one dude.
She's just fit.
She's got muscle.
That's the muscle.
She's,
she's very thin,
but she's got muscle.
She's probably,
I don't like some fucking crazy,
Ooh,
that looks real skinny,
but she's fucking 48 years old
or whatever the hell she is.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well you do start their women's start
losing fat in their face and that's one of
the things that really bums them out.
So they get fillers and it's
really kind of fucking creepy.
Fillers are really dark,
man.
It's really kind of a
weird thing when people do,
they shove like,
I don't know what it is,
some stuff in your fucking mug and it,
you know,
like when you see women with like
really puffy cheeks and shit,
but I think she still
looks hot as fuck man.
I look at that picture right there and my,
she's pretty hot dude.
She just looks fit to me.
She looks thin but fit.
She's probably just on
a really healthy diet.
Yeah.
You'd
cut off their hair though.
It's like Steve Jobs in that photo
where he's wearing a dress though,
kind of Steve jobs where he went,
oh,
she's not that thing.
You're crazy man.
She looks healthy,
she looks healthy,
but she looks like a person is
probably fanatical about exercise.
Yeah.
Look man.
Do you want to keep it
together at that age?
I just worked out today
with Steve Maxwell.
Steven Maxwell's is Kettlebell guy
that I'm friends with and he'll,
he comes over like a few times a year and
puts me through these brutal workouts.
Wow.
And uh,
yeah,
he's an animal bro.
And he's 59 years old,
50 fucking nine years old,
and he can do some shit that I can't do.
He could do a bunch of
different exercises I can't do.
He puts me through these wild fucking
yoga positions and it makes you do chin
ups where you,
you will fully extend,
pull your chin up all the way up and then
you hold it for five breaths and then
you go to your eyeballs,
you hold it to him for five breaths and
then you go above your head and you hold
it for five breaths and then you go
fully extended and then you pull yourself
back up and start all over again.
And it takes a long time.
It takes like 90 seconds
to do like three of them.
And when you're doing this man,
he does it like it's nothing
and he's fucking 59 years old.
Fuck that.
The dude's a stud.
He,
he can,
he can put it,
it's amazing.
Some people can fucking,
they just keep it together.
But the only way you do it like that,
like he's a world renowned
fitness instructor.
He works out every day.
He's teaching people,
he's training every
fucking day of his life,
like literally.
And he's training people how
to train everyday of his life.
So he just maintains fitness,
like to,
to look like Demi Moore and
basically essentially 50 years old.
Yet I guess they're saying that she lost
98 pounds up to 98 pounds of what she
used to weigh.
That's what they're saying.
Oh,
you making up a number?
No,
it's right here.
This is reported to have
plummeted to around seven stone.
That's 98 pounds for all you
folks on this side of the pond.
That doesn't mean she lost 98 pounds.
That means she changed.
As I said,
plummeted.
I just,
this is a little baby going to help you.
So good news.
I have something to announce.
A,
you already know about it
already about dust squad.
We are moving to the Pasadena Ice House.
The studio.
Yeah.
So we're going to set up a professional
studio out there so that all the lie
from the Ice House shows and
all the desk watches and uh,
I talked to,
we talked to was the fleshlight about
sponsoring the death squad show and the
Ice House show.
And if they don't,
well somebody else will and just holler
at us on Twitter and we'll figure
something out.
Only legit companies don't get
crazy with your pipe dreams.
Work it all out on your
own before you come to us.
Cause Shit ain't cheap.
But uh,
if uh,
we do set up that uh,
set up,
uh,
the,
um,
the studio there at the podcast or the
podcast studio where they're at a ice
house,
it'd be amazing because it's really like
right around the corner from the stage,
from both stages and you
can just get offstage,
run out,
do a set,
come back and do the podcast.
And we did it one time and I thought
it was really fun and people liked it.
It's a fun energy.
Also there was a,
I just,
I don't know if you saw that there was
like 20 minutes of extra footage that we
recorded.
Me and Brendan that later that night
that we were so wasted I didn't remember
doing and I found it.
I put it up.
But you're in it too.
And we talked to the guy that made
the Burke Chrysler tee shirts.
Was that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Towards the very end.
And then some guy that said he was
going to verify me on Twitter anyways,
that's up on,
I just put up the podcast.
Yeah.
You need to verify them.
Whoever you are are,
boy,
I don't think they do that anymore though.
Really?
Yeah.
I think they stopped that whole thing.
Maybe you just want it to be your friend,
so he pretended he could verify you.
It'd be a cool thing to say,
Hey,
I can verify your baby.
Give me your number.
Yeah,
let me look it up,
sweetie.
What's up?
Want to get verified.
Hmm.
That's a new,
that's,
I'm gonna try that.
It's very important to be
verified on Twitter and you know,
there's a lot of fake people.
There's a lot of like,
I don't think Chris
Rock's really on Twitter.
It might be now.
He wasn't for a long time though.
Yeah,
there's a lot of,
I don't think Chappelle's on,
no,
I don't think so.
I think that's fair.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure.
And I think the fake ones
got a lot of people on it.
They think it's unfortunate,
uh,
tells on Twitter.
But he only used it like nine times ever.
But he started,
he tweeted something about his new shows.
Good.
What does a Dave's old porn on showtime.
Do you know anything about that now?
He an issue.
I didn't even know you had a new show.
Well,
he's coming on next Tuesday,
so he'll tell us what the fuck is up.
And then,
uh,
Shane Smith from Vice TV.
We're going to get him on
hopefully sometime next week.
Right.
But that guy,
man,
that's going to be the
nuttiest conversation ever.
That guy has been everywhere.
He seen some crazy and
he said he's got some
nutty slave footage to show us.
What?
Yeah,
yeah.
I don't,
I'll tell you exactly what he said.
It sounds,
it sounds pretty fucking nutty.
Missed the slave.
He's,
um,
you know,
he's one of those dudes,
it's like he's out there and like the
darkest parts of the world like all the
time filming it and bringing it back.
Like they're like living on the
edge of the edge of the edge,
you know,
that's a,
that's a crazy ass fucking show.
And this guy is one of the craziest,
he seems to embrace it.
It's really interesting.
You know why he's all,
I mean when they were in Liberia
and they were running around,
it was like,
fuck,
we almost got killed,
but it could have been dead.
They will like almost laughing about it.
He said he's got some end slave
footage that will blow your mind.
I'll bring you encase leads,
but I'm not sure what that means.
And Kay and Kay.
Anybody,
Bueller,
Kerrigan.
I don't know what it means,
but whatever slave footage,
um,
I want,
I want to say that whatever,
whatever fucking craziness he's got.
He,
they,
they're in there.
I told you about the Congo one,
you gotta wash that Congo one.
I don't know,
I've only watched one episode of it,
but just the one episode which leads
sort of just get things cooking.
They're just,
you look at the reality of that area and
you saw all my God like this is cool.
This is Fuck Mad Max Mad Max.
If they were living in
Mad Max and they saw this,
they'd be like,
dude,
that's terrifying.
Like Mad Max Times.
It looks like like a break from the Congo.
You'd be like,
oh we have to do is fight for gasoline
and stay away from thunder dome and
everything's cool.
You know,
and you look at Liberia,
you look at the Congo and you look in
all these places like these fucking dirt
roads and like hot and people pile
into the street and just looks like,
like you went back in time.
It's like you like Yo,
you went back in time to like
some dark age when people,
people were still developing humanity
and developing culture and developing,
you know,
a community,
the sense of community and you
just shoved them all together.
And gave them houses and
gave them clothes and cars.
And it's just,
it's almost like,
it's like you can't believe that
there's a part of the world that's that,
that nuts.
And when they were given
the figures about the Congo,
but how many people have
been murdered there?
You just go,
what box?
It's like millions of people.
Millions.
And just think of the idea of
a million being a thousand,
a thousand times.
I think about there's multiple,
multiple millions and millions
of people have died in the Congo.
And think about the,
just the,
the,
the enormity of the mass of
all those bodies together.
And you realize how crazy it is.
These fucks went there and they went
there to film the fucking video.
Oh my God.
It's nuts,
dude.
Everyone's got guns and machine
guns and AK 47 and there,
there's minors and they're fucking
putting people through slave labor to get
them to pull out,
you know,
rocks and minerals that we're
gonna use to make cell phones.
It's,
the world is crazy as fuck right now.
And it,
a lot of it is just we know,
you know,
a lot of it is just we know we're
constantly inundated by information.
When I was a kid,
if you wanted to find out about EDI mean
you gotta you got to do some searching.
You know,
you got to go to a library,
you had to buy a book,
you had to talk to a teacher.
You know Mr. Johnson Q.
Explain to me how EDI mean rose to power.
I was a long story could and he,
you know,
you,
you couldn't just get the
information but like Kadafi man,
we watched that guy's
last moments of life.
You know,
think about the difference in the leap
of information between now and 2030 years
ago.
We watched Kadafi died.
I watched a guy shove a stick up Qaddafi's
ass while he was covered in blood.
I saw him with no blood on him.
I heard gunshots and I see him
bleeding in the fucking head.
Yeah.
They pissed a whip.
That dude that kicked him.
You see him kicking him.
We watched that.
Yeah.
It's weird that the,
it's weird that that
happened because they aren't,
they fighting for,
you know,
like religious reasons,
like God,
you know God and stuff
like that and they're,
they're doing something that,
you know,
their guide,
it's like against what they believe in.
What you're trying to say is
that when they were doing it,
they say,
oh,
ah,
I know what they're singing.
They're saying God is great.
God is great.
You're cheering.
God is very religious people,
but yet they're murdering
and torturing and it seems,
yeah,
so stupid.
Well,
not only that,
they were parading him around on a truck
and they were holding him down with
shoes because shoes to them
or like really disrespectful.
Oh,
right.
Throwing a shoe at the president.
Yeah,
I remember that.
That was the one time where it illuminated
to me how much of it is just a job
for George Bush.
He's just a guy with a job.
When that guy started throwing the shoes
at him and he had a little smile on his
face,
he's like,
Gee Whiz,
finally I get a little fun on the job.
Right.
But he had a little fun on the job today.
Normally my job is bullshit and to
people while Dick Cheney fucks the world,
but today I got the ducks
shoes,
honey.
It was fun.
I was like,
come on you little fella.
You ain't got no fucking arm.
Throw it.
Throw no shoes.
It's like he seemed human to me for like
a brief moment because to me Bush was
always this moron.
It like stood on a battleship with,
you know,
mission accomplished in the background
when fucking nothing had been
accomplished.
Like you're talking crazy.
What are you going to call it
first and then we win the war.
The fuck are you talking about?
How's it mission accomplished?
Was 100,000 fucking troops
over there and you know,
50,000 deadly war
machine circling the sky,
dropping bombs on people.
What the fuck are you talking about?
What was your mission?
Mission accomplished.
We stolen lied.
You know,
if that's what their
mission accomplish was,
we got over there,
we got Halliburton contracts,
we did it,
we did it.
We,
we sold the weapons of
mass destruction lie,
Yay,
mission accomplished.
Then it's mission accomplished.
So I always looked at him as being,
this is fucking new
world order mouthpiece,
this,
you know,
this evil person who is perpetrating
these things on the American people.
And then I looked at him when that guy
was throwing a shoe at him and I was
like,
he's just a guy,
is the normal guy.
Just a guy who got duped.
And the reason why he comes off dom
is because part of the reason why he's
weighed now than when he was the governor.
If you go back and listen to,
like George Bush had speeches,
George Bush jr w when he was a young
man and he was campaigning for governor,
he was quite eloquent.
I mean,
it's really a shocking
difference between that level of,
of,
of the ability to communicate that he
had back then and how he came across as,
you know,
maybe not the most
educated guy in the world,
you know,
but at least he was focused and prepared
and he spoke very clearly and he seemed
very confident.
Whereas you see him
like as a an older man,
it's like he just barely fucking phoning
it in and that's what it was like.
He was like Jack on
lost in the last season.
Who's phoning it in?
He was just tired of the whole charade
and he was forced into that position and
so that's why he said
stuff with the knife,
no passion behind it.
Like the evil doers,
he would say like stupid shit because
he would get off script and he really
didn't have any passion for it,
so he didn't have,
it's not even that he was dumb.
He said he never thought about it.
He's like,
he had to shut himself off of the reality
of what being the fucking president
was because everybody,
when they're a little boy,
thinks that the reality of being the
president is all you get to be the fucking
guy who fixes everything and be the next
Teddy Roosevelt would be the guy who
turns America around.
Meanwhile,
all you are is just strapping
a condom on this giant machine,
this giant war machine as
it fucks America in the ass,
and that's what you're doing.
You're there to provide the condoms so
American doesn't know what the fuck is
happening.
You know,
you're,
you're there to the,
to put the put on the show.
You're there to tell everybody
that everything is okay.
We have to insert this dick
in your ass to fight terror.
Oh,
okay.
You know,
it's like,
that's what he was,
he was the mouthpiece,
the mouthpiece for the monster and
that guy throwing the shoe at it just
illuminated it.
I saw him with a glimmer in his eye,
like a young guy again and meanwhile
he's just a fucking 60 year old man,
60 year old man who just got sucked
into the wrong fucking crowd.
Never really was ambitious,
never really cared that much.
If you look at his past,
he was like a lazy guy.
So when all of a sudden
he's in a position,
boy,
he's going to be set for life financially.
He's fucking president now.
He's even in his second term,
like he just had no ambition.
You're talking about a guy who choked
himself unconscious on a pretzel and fell
and knocked himself out.
You remember that Shit.
You had like a black eye or that was a
story that totally seems like the most
ridiculous story ever.
Maybe his dad beat the fuck out of them.
Could you imagine if he was like doing
something wrong or he said something
wrong and his dad put on leather
gloves and like beat him and fries.
They'll put on like SAP gloves.
Just beat his ass in front of
everybody to show him like,
this is not how the new world order's
run and just fucking beat his ass,
you know,
just to let them know,
motherfucker,
we're crazy.
All right,
we're really the throat planes into
buildings or I will punch you right in the
fucking face.
I wouldn't put it past on him.
His Dad was the head of the fucking CIA.
His Dad,
they always thought he was like a Wimp,
you know,
like there was like the big thing on,
on the older Bush,
you know,
I was like,
oh well the wimp president.
And like,
you know,
they look,
it was on a,
like Newsweek.
I was reading very recently.
Um,
he was on the cover of Newsweek and it
was talking about him being a wimp and it
was like a very controversial
thing because here's a guy who's,
you know,
I'm going to run the fucking biggest
nuclear power in the free world.
And they're saying,
is he a wimp?
Like,
wow,
like that's a label,
man.
You stick that and a magazine,
a fucking magazine sticks that.
But meanwhile,
this guy was the head of the fucking CIA.
You know what kind of Evil Shit you have
to do to be the head of the CIA to get
to the top of that monster.
The CIA's a shadow government.
We have a shadow government that
is allowed to murder people.
They're allowed to go out of
the country and murder people.
You know,
whether or not you call these people
terrorists or whether or not you can
connect them to illegal activity.
The bottom line is the CIA,
including American civilians.
The CIA goes over there and
kill these motherfuckers and,
and they don't do shit about it.
Nobody does a fucking thing about it.
The government doesn't prosecute him.
They don't go after him.
For these,
these drone attacks that they do.
They do some crazy shit,
man.
And this guy was the head of that.
He was the head so maybe he didn't have
to fucking lay the gloves to George
Little Georgie.
Skim a fucking stiff jab in the face.
Bitch will fucking kill you.
This is how it works.
No,
you can't go back to own a baseball team,
right?
Yeah.
And he throws a pretzel down on
him and hits him in the face of,
yes,
you have to say that you choked on
his bitch or something like that.
Like you have to make it seem
like they'd most like bitchy
being they get a black car.
Maybe he was trying to get
some head from a tranny.
I found out that it was a training and
then the trainee beat his ass and he
couldn't say anything
cause he was a president.
Training Lips,
carbs.
It could be.
Did you hear about the blacklist
bill that that they're,
they're trying to pass a black list called
the blacklist bill and it pretty much
will make like Twitter,
youtube,
Facebook,
like those companies be 100% responsible
for the content so it could kill pretty
much killed Twitter,
anything like that.
Fucking con it would make it a felony to,
to stream unlicensed content,
video game play throughs,
like a karaoke songs,
music videos,
like all that shit.
And I go make it a felony.
So Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
So it's pretty much
going to start censoring.
The Internet's going to start it.
Who is allowing people to
continue to come up with?
Can we have a moratorium on new laws?
Just like obviously shit is
spiraling out of control.
There's a million new laws introduced
every year that upset people that we don't
have a chance to truly
reconcile and understand and,
and,
and just talk about,
you know,
just a dress.
There's too many of them.
There's new ones every day,
whether it's medical marijuana,
they're trying to do this to try and do
that with vitamins and fucking make them
prescription only to try to do this,
to try and do that.
It's,
it's a constant stream of bullshit.
You fucking criminals and I hope,
I hope that it doesn't
through Bhs stop free speech.
They're trying to stop people
from doing what they're doing now,
which is organizing.
When do you think they are
going to start making a sensor?
Podcasts.
They can't.
I think they're not because
there's too many of them.
There's too many of them.
There's too much.
It's too much going on.
What does the sensor censorship for?
If it's free and you actually
have to download it and it's,
you know,
it's labeled mature,
it seems to be fucking pretty simple.
Unless you're going to start
censoring movies and censoring songs,
which you know they've tried,
they've tried in the past
and it essentially they do
censor movies because if
you go above are,
you can't have any
sexual content and movie,
like real interaction.
Do you remember Brown bunny?
Do you remember that movie?
No.
It was a Vincent Gallo
movie and it was what?
That,
I forget that chicks chicks name.
So there's a van g Chloe
Shalane going game anyway.
She sucks his cock for real man.
Really?
Yeah.
That's part of the plot.
Part of the plot was like,
it's just like this really hot scene.
And they said,
well,
we're just going to really do it,
so really act it out.
So.
So she no,
no.
Chloe,
Chloe.
Yeah.
You watched the scene,
you'll just,
just Google seen from Brown bunny.
Wow.
And you know Vincent Gallo is standing
up and he pulls out his dick and Chloe's
stuff.
I can go there and eat.
How did you say her name is?
She,
she sucked his cock and the nuts
in her face and it's 100% legit.
Wow.
First of all,
his cock is not that impressive.
Are they dating at the time?
I think they were.
That makes sense.
Or that might've been just what they
put on the press release to make it seem
not so bad.
Well,
they are dating,
you know?
Wow.
Yeah.
So,
I mean,
but,
and everybody got mad at
them for that by the way.
And he sort of blacklisted
because of that.
Wow.
Yeah.
He doesn't really work that much
and he's really a good actor,
but he's really,
he seems to be really crazy.
He's like a real dark
weirdo sort of a character.
And I remember he was,
he's been in like vodka ads and shit and
he's always the guy with like long sort
of greasy hair and there's a bunch
of dirty heroin looking girls around.
I'm looking at suck dicks.
Ever seen those pictures?
Yeah.
Well that's him and he's just,
he's fucking,
he's a weird guy.
I mean to do that and think it's
okay to do that and I move it.
I'm just going to pull
macaca you suck it for real.
Okay.
Yeah.
We're going to leave this in yo watts.
You gotta leave in the cock sucking part.
How can we can't just imply it,
man.
I mean,
sexy enough,
you know,
just seeing her head and seeing though,
you don't have to actually show your Dick.
And I'm how long showed all,
man,
that's what's really going on.
I want to show what's happening.
I want to show how to be realist,
the realist of the real.
But at one point in time,
you know that was where people
thought it was going to go.
When deep throat came out,
people got in line like and went to that
on Bates deep throat came out and it
was like a real movie that
was a pornographic movie
and that had really not been
fucking popular before that,
you know,
they're really,
I mean there was behind the green
curtain or door with Marilyn Chambers.
That was one that was like along similar
lines and there's like a picture from
that I saw online of Johnny Carson
waiting in line for deep throat.
Apparently they were interviewing
him and he'll just like,
it was like acceptable to go
and see this and go see this.
This movie where people actually
fucked because it was a movie they had.
They didn't have porno movies like that.
So because it was a movie,
they trick people and all of a sudden
people were in this movie watching some
checks,
sucks some decks.
You know,
it's kind of crazy when
you think about it.
That wasn't that long ago.
And you've got to wonder what if things,
uh,
you know,
weren't,
maybe they loosened up quicker.
You know,
what,
what if,
if that was introduced today,
what if we never had porn before and
we have this sort of crazy environment
where we have right now.
And then all of a sudden someone started,
it would be porn used
to be just like scenes,
but then someone put together a real
good movie where people actually fucking
it.
And it was like the first
one ever done like man,
and maybe it was an idea before its
time because you gotta think of Johnny
fucking Carson who's like,
you know,
the weird head of the tonight show,
hit me as America Pie as you can get,
as across the board,
normal as you can get.
And he's waiting in
line to see deep throat.
Well you would have to
hide that pee wee Herman.
Just a few decades later,
it goes to jail for
beating off in a theater.
You know,
it's,
and it's sought thought of
as being really ultra CD,
like,
oh my God,
he went to a theater when they
were playing pornographic movies.
This is just a few decades later,
man.
It's interesting.
It could,
I wonder what could have happened.
I wonder if it's one of those things
where we just as zigged when we could have
zagged,
you know,
and maybe when that happened,
they could've started doing,
like,
there could have been like a normal genre.
Like you'd go to see,
you know,
a fucking Jennifer Aniston
movie and it was an ex,
Jennifer Aniston would get fucked.
Gerard Butler would just
fucking dig in that.
There'll be craziest shit
if you watch a real movie.
Like that's stupid fucking movie
they had where one of them was,
uh,
a convict or something.
They're handcuffed together.
How much better would that movie be of
Jennifer Aniston was talking as deck,
of course,
be a way better moving.
It'd be a way better movie.
It would be fun.
You know,
it'd be like,
damn,
that girl's got a great mouth.
It'd be fun.
You know that big Chin really aids when
she's blowing you because it gives you
like extra coverage of
your balls on her chin.
It's like more chin to go around.
That's how you would look at it.
It'd be fun,
but instead it didn't go that way.
You can imagine if the porno stars
are the ones that made the big cash,
that was like the real,
those are real money and if you didn't,
if you were,
if you're a hot chick and
you're too scared to do porn,
yeah,
well you know,
and you'd be on a Sitcom I guess,
which you couldn't do any movies.
The real big money movies that
people want to watch people fuck.
That could been really
easily been possible.
If you look at how God damn
popular pornography is,
it's really just a matter of a public
attitude about it because pornography is
gigantic on the Internet.
I mean they think something like 30 to
40 of all packages that are flying around
being downloaded on the internet,
have some sort of pornography on them.
That's amazing.
I mean,
that's a,
just a staggering number.
When you think about the billions
of human beings on the Internet,
I mean,
how many billions or on
the internet worldwide,
is it like four or something like that?
There's like almost 7 billion people.
Let's be conservative and say
it's 3 billion on the Internet.
You think that's conservative
or think that's like,
let's go crazy and say 2 billion.
Let's say it's only 2
billion people online.
That's a lot of fucking people.
2 billion people and 30 to 40% of it is
just dicks in pussies and sucking cock
and that's all it is.
It's amazing.
Then when you stop and
think about the demand,
the sheer demand,
and yet when you look around,
you wouldn't know when
you go to the movies,
it's not represented.
It's is not.
You go to the magazine store,
it's not represented.
Sure.
There's some like weird shit up at the
top that sealed off and plastic and
they're so fucking big,
you know,
subscription thing over the front cover.
So you can't even see what it's in there
until you open the plastic and yeah,
it's a sort of represented,
but not 30 to 40%.
Not even close.
It's not.
It's like 1% maybe of the,
all the magazines at a Barnes and noble,
you know,
1% of them may be or pornographic.
It's even in there.
They're never like hardcore either.
It's just like they show
you like tits and shit.
They show you like a little little
spread apart if you're lucky girls,
peanut on somebody.
No.
That's why I can't understand why like
magazines like playboy or giving $1
million to Lindsay Lohan when you
know how the Internet works nowadays.
If Lindsay Lohan,
there's a photo of her from playboy.
Everybody's going to have
it in like two seconds.
Yeah.
They're counting on the rubes.
The count on the people that just
can't get online quick enough.
They don't know anybody with the forum.
The forum,
I go on the forum and
then what do I do it?
They don't know that.
They don't know what they're doing.
Man,
they're just fucking knuckleheads.
I feel bad for the board on vacation.
Maybe.
I feel bad for my mom cause she,
she recently,
she,
they still don't have
internet at her house,
you know,
like Dsl.
So she now got a hot spot phone,
a smart phone that has a hot spot so
she can get on the Internet through her
phone,
you know.
Wow.
So it's stupid.
It's shit.
It's not even a four g phone.
She's a three g and a,
so now she's,
she's has fast I internet and we wouldn't
have had the internet or like a whole
life.
And even when porn started coming up,
it used to be like
really slow loading porn.
So it's like,
oh my God,
there's the bottom of balls.
When we were talking about that in the
last podcast with that guy that got
caught who was doing
the gay porn and that,
my friend actually had to sit in a room
with them and download the picture as a
picture is downloading.
Yes.
He's more of his head and then
he sees a dick in his mouth.
Yeah.
Well,
it's funny how that sequence,
we kind of,
you know,
she now just go to a website by mistake
and it's like buttholes assholes calm
shots instantly.
Instantly.
Yeah.
She has no,
no.
And she had,
it doesn't have any kind of like warning
or training for the Internet as a
windows computer too doesn't she's.
Yes.
And she's
already installed everything.
Putting,
put her social security number
signed up for Netflix three times somehow.
Oh No,
I told you about the time that
somebody hacked me on Twitter.
They'll tell you about
that happens all the time,
man.
I got it yesterday because
somebody sent me like a,
hey check out this photo of you.
I can't believe you
have that in your mouth.
And I'm like,
what?
And I click on it and then the website
turned to I Twitter but it looked exactly
like Twitter and had me log in.
Of course I didn't it,
I didn't do it.
Well,
yeah,
with me.
I had to I to look at something,
I think I had to click on
something and somehow or another,
you know there's a lot of times when
you like install like quick vid are all
these little,
little,
you know,
picked Vic and the little little fucking
websites and software that runs videos
and pictures.
There's like some user agreements that
they're creepy like they're allowed to
like use your Twitter and tweet shit.
Yeah Dude,
this is fucking tweet.
It said on my,
on my Twitter I that I just entered a
contest for an iPad two and I looked at
that and someone said,
what do you [inaudible] is this spam?
Like someone was saying it's spam,
you know,
are you,
did you really enter the for
an iPad two and I want to what?
So I go to my timeline.
When I was busy,
I wasn't,
I wasn't online,
I wasn't doing shit.
Somehow or another through my Twitter,
they had tweeted that I had
signed up for a contest,
which I never signed up
for a contest in the link.
When you click the link
was this scam website,
do you think?
Uh,
do you remember like doing
one of those where like,
oh,
I got to login?
No,
I did not log in.
I don't know how the fuck they did it.
I don't know what they did.
That's weird.
I did not.
No,
I did not log in and it was a new program
that I had somehow or another that
recently got on my Twitter and
on top of that they fought.
I fought,
was following them on Twitter
and I did not follow them.
They,
they followed,
they put that in my Twitter.
They made me follow them
and they made a tweet.
So I had to change my password,
but I went to it.
I went to the website and the guy
had like 100,000 fucking hits.
Wow.
And would you report it?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I did.
He had 100,000 followers on his
as Twitter site and I was like,
this is incredible.
I've never heard of this guy.
He's got 100,000 fucking followers.
And you know,
I,
I tweeted online,
I'm not going to say the guy's name,
I'm not going to say that.
The,
I don't want to give them any publicity,
you know,
and I'm not going to be
to hate what he's doing.
Okay.
What he's the owner is doing is just
selling traffic and trying to like,
you know,
do scams and trying to get
people to his website with scams.
He's not stealing any credit
card information as far
as I know he's doing stuff
that's like,
right.
All your shit.
Slightly sleazy.
You know,
I'm like tweets,
if he had your login somehow
he probably could download it.
All your private messages.
Yeah.
But there might be.
It could be.
Yeah.
But there wasn't,
but um,
the,
the point is that I don't think
what he's doing as a terrible thing,
but it just,
it was creepy.
It was creepy that all of a sudden some
guy like makes a tweet from my Twitter
about some fucking contest.
And then,
you know,
it turns out that I had met this dude,
he had been to like a bunch of you fcs
and they had pictures with me and he's
like made a little blog about
it and that's when it got
really creepy cause you made it,
this little blog about
it and then send me,
sent a tweet about it
with my name in it in uh,
the title of this blog.
And I got the same tweet from no bullshit,
maybe 50 or 60 other Twitter sites.
So he has like all these fake Twitter
accounts and all of these accounts.
When I would go to them,
they would have all the exact same tweets.
So he just has like,
just,
uh,
just swarming the Internet was spam and
bullshit and then infecting your Twitter
and then tweeting from your
Twitter and making you follow him.
So out of the hundred thousand
people that were following him,
you know,
who knows how many of them
voluntarily signed up for it?
Cause I know I fucking sure as fuck
didn't nobody uses my Twitter except me.
I,
I don't,
no one even has the password except me.
No one's,
I don't have an assistant
that does that Shit,
you know?
So when I know who I follow,
I wasn't following that guy and
he was the last one I followed.
So it was like a recent thing and
I looked at it and I was like,
this is nuts man.
This is what,
it's really nothing,
you know,
cause it's isn't,
there's no point
done.
It shows that,
that somehow he got into something
exerts you could be in your email,
you can be in your,
which just shows the
vulnerability of at least Twitter.
Right.
You know,
and you know,
of course people have done
that on Facebook and then
a bunch of other things and
you know,
it's,
it's a common thing on the Internet
to misrepresent who you are.
You know?
I don't know.
It's,
uh,
it's just,
when you have information online,
you know,
and then they're putting it on servers
and people are going to be able to get
it.
Man.
It's just,
they're just going to be able to get it.
You have to assume that the ultimate,
like the fight right now is everybody's
trying to keep everybody else from
getting at their information,
getting out of their data,
getting it.
But the real truth is eventually
there's going to be no secrets.
You're not going to be the w.
The idea of privacy is
going to be out the window.
It's not going to exist anymore.
And essentially that's probably what's
going to be the doom of the financial
system as well.
It'll be impossible to hold onto money.
There'll be,
it'll be impossible to,
it won't make any sense.
Everyone's going to have to
access to everybody else's money.
You're just,
cause we don't steal from each other.
Right.
It's like the interconnectivity will
eventually reach some sort of a boiling
point when if you look at what's,
what's what people are
capable of doing now,
it's stealing credit card
numbers and you know,
and and essentially getting at the ones
and Zeros that you'll use to get by and
those ones and Zeros are all
tallied and scored online.
Eventually people are going to get to a
point where those don't mean anything.
They're going to get into those things
and they're just gonna fuck the whole
system sideways and it
won't be worth anything.
Yeah.
Well I've had my credit card
stolen numbers stolen twice,
three times since I've lived in La.
Yeah.
I've had it stolen
before to a gas station.
Gas Station.
Yeah.
And in waiters,
waiters will have little readers.
So when you pay for your bill,
they'll come in and just
like scan your thing in.
They're in their apron and
then give it back to yeah.
That was a weird feeling when I got it.
Oh,
from my accountants.
Are you buying $1,000 worth of chocolate?
Yeah.
That was like what they would,
they were buying shit.
I wish.
Well they were buying
things that they could sell,
like they're buying.
Um,
like the gift cards.
Yeah.
And then,
you know,
hey man,
you want me to get a girl?
Feel good.
I've got a hundred dollar gift card,
Bro.
$20 notice I made him an urban character.
Yeah.
Why was that?
I Dunno.
I was going to go with Armenian,
but I wasn't confident with my,
my,
that sounds just so standard.
So formulaic.
I didn't want to go with that one.
So,
um,
uh,
in Canada,
Dave,
um,
this is our fucking big news.
All the experts,
a coalition of prominent BC police
officer's health professionals,
leaguer experts,
academics and academics are calling for
the legalization and regulated sale of
marijuana.
It's really kind of nuts,
man.
Dude,
come on man.
A coalition.
Listen to that.
Of police officers off of the roof.
That's
why.
Why do we,
why is gay associated
with a list sometimes?
What does that cause
it's usually have Cox,
Cox in her mouth.
Is that what it is?
Painful.
But how come girls don't get sloppy
when they're sucking Dick all the time?
They don't start Lisbon.
If you'd imagine if that would like,
you found out that girls,
like if you talked to
girls like y'alls girls,
Lisbon like crazy.
She been sucking dicks all weekend.
And when you suck decks,
like it feels good for the guy,
but I'm going to lift.
You're going to make me laugh baby.
It feels so good though.
I don't care.
I don't care about that list.
It doesn't,
it doesn't turn you off from nine lift.
Has a lot of guys have fed,
reminds them of all the of
the Dick fell off packed.
Like if you have a bank of dicks you
can only suck a certain amount and then
your lips just give out and your tongue
gets all sloppy and you produce extra
saliva and it not only do you
list be spit on people dudes,
it's still want their dick.
Sorry,
I don't care baby.
I don't care because a new doctor
and he's going to glean your drain,
your salivary glands.
The bad news is you got to
drink water every 30 seconds,
but the good news is you won't this
pending and their teeth are all nicely
polished just for the front being
rubbed against somebody talks.
Yeah,
they don't even really a brush.
It's Cox or and going and then
pushing that all the food.
You know that's how the head
of the Dick has designed these,
you know the head of the Dick is designed
to actually like the reason why your
Dick is like pointing at the top and it
has like that little bulging area that
like goes in and then the shaft comes out.
It's cause it's designed to push down
into the woman's vagina and squirt all the
sperm up and then pull the sperm out.
That's what it's designed for.
If you like,
look at the way the head is,
you know,
see the head is like sort of like a
helmet with the idea is that the way it's
shaped,
it would go in and whatever sperm was
in there would actually get pressed up
against the Dick and forced up to the
top where it was stored on this lip and
then you would pull it out and
then you shoot your own in there.
Like what?
What does,
the whole idea of breeding is designed
under the idea that someone had already
fucked her first.
For sure.
The whole design of the Dick
is designed to just like,
we just get this,
get this out of the way.
Someone's fucked her.
Okay,
you gotta get that juice out
and put your own in this,
the only one going have kids.
Fucking amazing.
It's really amazing when you
stop and think about that.
There was a theory for a while
but it was disproven where uh,
they were,
they were thinking that a certain
amount of sperm were attacks berm.
I love this idea.
It was a great idea and I really wished
it was evidence for it cause I would
have some material on it.
I could almost like ignore it
just to do a bid on it but fuck,
I can't,
it's not true.
That,
and what they were saying was that a
certain amount of sperm were actually
designed just to go in and
attack and kill other sperm.
But it was like this one guy who had
this theory and apparently a lot of other
people are like,
where's the fucking evidence for it?
It's like this is nuts.
This is like how do you,
how do you,
what?
What are they killing each other with?
They have bats,
you know,
he's killer scrub.
They just fucking cells.
It just loads.
You know what he talking about?
Loads that kill what bitch you
reading some science fiction.
You know what?
I love the idea though.
One of my favorite things to do.
You ever take your ball skin and then
wrap it around your boss and your Dick and
make a little like backwards bowling ball.
Have you ever done that?
One of my favorite things to do.
You said so if someone says,
Hey Brian,
no,
would you like to do ride a race car one?
No.
Like Dick Suck.
It freaks them out because they can't
understand what's going on cause they
don't know balls that well.
And at that point
they'll probably be like,
why am I here?
What have I done to deserve this guy in
front of me pulling his ball skin over
his belly button?
And if you have a lot of hair,
they can't find the scene.
Amazing
backwards bullying Paul.
No,
I've never heard of that man.
Do it.
To go back to this,
um,
this illegalized BC thing,
one of the reason why they're,
uh,
thinking about legalizing marijuana is
the results from Portugal apparently.
So Portugal,
they decriminalized all drugs,
drug use in 2001.
And the theory was that
focusing on prevention and
treatment rather than jailing
users would be the most beneficial way.
So Portugal try decriminalization and,
uh,
the use of possession of heroin,
cocaine,
marijuana,
LSD and other illicit drugs.
All those were decriminalized.
And five years later they found that the
number of street drug overdoses dropped
from 400 to two 90 annually.
And the new number of HIV cases
linked dropped from 1400 to about 400.
So a thousand less HIV cases and you know,
110 less,
um,
uh,
drug overdoses.
I mean that's a lot man.
You know,
and the dealings drugs is still illegal.
You still can't deal it,
but the users aren't jailed.
Instead they're putting in front of a
panel that includes one lawyer or a judge
and a health or a social services worker.
And the panel can recommend treatment and,
or a small fine or no sanction at all.
So it's based on,
you know,
what kind of an impact
you're having on society.
I mean,
you,
uh,
you do and drugs then breaking people's
windows you'd do and drugs and shitting
in the street.
Well they might find you for shitting in
the street cause someone's got to clean
that up.
But it's amazing that it's really,
it's,
it's shown that it's better to have these
things legal and decriminalize and not
lock up the users.
So Canada is looking at
this and they're going,
why the fuck are we in?
The reason why,
the number one reason why is America,
America wants candidate to keep their
fucking laws exactly the same way that
constantly been pushing,
putting pressure on them.
It's just embarrassing.
It's getting to the point where
it's embarrassing that marijuana,
it's embarrassing.
It is embarrassing.
It's ridiculous.
It's like no,
no other end people.
So it's just drug.
You know what he fucking drug him in.
You need a drug that's not even it.
Even if I never wanted to do marijuana
again for the rest of my life,
I would still say that you telling me I
can't do it as the most ridiculous thing
I've ever heard in my life.
It's like if you are living alone on an
island and there was only four people on
the island and one of them said,
if you smoke weed,
I'm going to lock in jail.
The other three would be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Dude,
we've got other shit to worry about.
Why do you care if I want to sit on the
island and get high once I do my chores?
What do you give a fuck if I'm productive
members so well that that one person
at a four is just as ridiculous as
what we've got going on right now.
What we've got going on right now is
some people and they're telling other
people what they can and
can't do with their body.
It doesn't hurt a God damn thing.
And that's stupid.
And at least Canada's
figuring that out first.
But they still deported
that Mark Emery Guy,
the poor fucking guy,
man was living free in his own
country and he was selling seeds,
seeds to a goddamn plant.
That makes you silly.
What are you going,
you got to go pee?
I'm going to talk about myself.
This is ridiculous.
You fucking weak bladder bitch,
by the way.
Um,
I will be playing the,
uh,
UFC drinking game this weekend,
this weekend.
Uh,
the UFC is in Vegas and it's
a Bj Penn versus Nick Diaz.
Unfortunately,
George St Pierre was
supposed to be fighting,
was supposed to be fighting Carlos
condit and fucking amazing fight,
but it was really looking forward to,
it was the whole car.
It was kind of crazy.
It started out,
it was a,
Nick Diaz was supposed to be fighting
George Saint Pierre and Nick Diaz kind of
flaked at a few press conferences and
then they pulled them out and said,
all right,
Carlos Khan is now fighting GSP.
And everybody was like,
what?
And then they said,
Nick Diaz,
you still want to fight,
you got to fucking do press all this shit.
And he's like,
okay,
all right,
you're fighting Bj Penn.
And everybody's like,
Holy Shit.
Cause actually that made it even
like that's pretty God damn exciting.
It was supposed to be GSP versus um,
uh,
be GSP versus condit,
which is an amazing fight.
GSP versus Diaz Rather,
And he got,
you know,
condit versus GM versus Bj Penn,
which is another amazing fight.
So they essentially just
swapped and it was eagle then.
Unfortunately it was even rather,
but unfortunately GSP hurt
his knee and he fell out.
He,
I think he had a,
a strain or a strained MCL and uh,
it's gonna be a couple of months.
It has to do rehab on it
and shit and so really,
really big,
big disappointment.
But the rest of the card
is still fucking sick.
There's a lot of,
a lot of good fights on this.
Joey's coming down with me and um,
Jamie Kilstein is coming up from New York.
I was bringing his little
brother should be fun.
I'm looking forward to it.
I haven't been to Vegas
in a long time either.
It's been a while.
It's supposed to,
to a Halloween party with that South Park.
Uh Oh real.
The people that work for south
park or throwing a party and
I don't know what to go as it
cause everyone that goes there.
I went last year and the year
before and every time they go there,
they,
everyone goes overboard.
Like everyone's like spending
months on their costumes.
You know you should be the
exploding desk squad cat,
but yeah,
but what am I going?
Where am I going to get that and get a
cat outfit and some fucking fix that good
idea.
Strap yourself together.
Get a watch.
Like a flavor flav clock.
Oh,
that's a good idea.
We started with a thought,
don't go with a Hitler mustache.
She got to get rid of iTunes.
Where you should take that off the,
yeah,
just take that off anyway.
It's stupid.
Why?
Given that stupid cat a Hitler,
Hitler's chaplain.
Chaplain.
It's Hitler because Hitler is
after chaplain every everyone else.
It's a mental test to see if you're a
Hitler chaplain and it just to see your
personality.
It's a personality test.
Have a little,
or it could be Michael Jordan
because he pulled it exactly.
It's to Jordan,
but that's a goofy move on Michael Jordan.
How big is his ego?
Yeah,
Hitler mustache.
I got the Kingsborough cat too,
bro.
I got the kick ass girl costume,
but I think it's,
it's too tight because it's
a girl's extra large girl,
but that's only like a 32 waist,
like gut hangs out of it.
It's hard.
It's actually pretty funny looking.
I don't know if I want to embarrass
myself because that's embarrassing.
You know when you have like a super tight
and you're dressed up as a girl at the
same time,
well you're supposed to be funny,
right?
I guess you gotta be careful though.
You're going to,
are you going to hang out with your girl?
Yeah.
You don't want to be too humiliating.
Exactly.
So the other thing is she's going
to go is when would be cool,
sexy,
windy,
sexy Wendy from the hamburger place.
Yes.
I'm going to be,
I'm a Zombie.
She goes,
he's dead.
Okay.
I was going to say she goes
a cow with a bullet hole.
Yeah.
Can do that too.
I was going to be Dave Thomas,
but it's like decaying.
He still has a little tie on and stuff,
but you don't have to shave your beard.
I know.
It won't take two weeks,
two weeks to go back.
That's not a bad one.
If she got a theme thing going on,
but then you know,
you've kind of be in the Beta to your,
your chick's lead,
you know,
you're following her lead.
You know,
maybe it could be a wolf that,
that the big bad wolf that
catches Wendy in the woods.
Or it could be Ronald,
you'd be aware of wolf
catches her on the way home.
Is there a bringing bonds back and
just give her the Dick in the bushes?
Is there a tee?
Somebody said that there's
a TV show from the 80s.
I was about werewolves that
Joe Rogan was a character in,
in the,
the name Joe Rogan was a character.
Yeah.
Come on.
Probably some nonsense from Wikipedia.
I didn't check.
So they had a god damn,
uh,
some website.
I won't even give them the
dignity of naming the website.
Had a list of a werewolf movies,
the best werewolf movies ever.
My God.
Is it a piece of shit list?
First of all,
they had this,
they didn't have the howling on,
which is a goddamn Travis to,
you got to have the howling if
you're going to have werewolf movies.
There's really only two.
There's American Werewolf
in London and the howling,
those are the only two good ones.
American Werewolf in
London being far superior.
That's the greatest werewolf
movie of all time for sure.
But they have like ginger snaps,
which I saw,
which was the werewolf was so bad.
It looked like someone drew a
scary face on a balloon werewolf.
A TV series for the 1987 to 1988 the
character's name was Alamo Joe Rogan.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That is weird man.
Wasn't Alamo Joe Rogan a
fucking baseball player.
Wasn't that like a famous black baseball
player or there was like no rocket Joe
Rogan or some point that Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan baseball player.
Yeah.
Famous black baseball player.
But what it was is he had
like a nickname though.
It was like hurricane something
or hold stick just right.
Uh,
Joe Rogan.
Baseball player.
Yeah,
their asshole.
Don't write that but cool.
Don't worry about all the bullet.
Yeah.
Bullet Joe Rogan.
He was in the Negro League.
Isn't that crazy?
See the resemblance.
It's a lot like me.
She just,
we just had a failure.
We have a mic,
arm failure and choked down.
Hey.
Oh,
where'd it go?
It just gave up.
We don't use the best components here
at the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Let me fit this spring back.
All right.
Turn down your mic real quick.
So why do you do that?
Uh,
we owe,
this is how I guess we can say it's
a death squad as a comedy show.
Uh,
tomorrow at the Ice House
we have Duncan Trussell,
uh,
is going to be there with little Hobo.
Our Magical Stephen is
easy from the league.
Uh,
Kevin Christie,
and it's same Tripoli's birthday tomorrow.
So we're having a huge party.
We're just going to get drunk and wasted
and Jason Tubo is going to drive us
all.
Uh,
so that's tomorrow at the Ice House.
Eight and 10 o'clock.
You got to icehouse website.
You can buy tickets now.
Last week it sold out.
We had Joe Rogan there and we're
also going to be recording a,
another,
a podcast there,
uh,
with Dunkin and,
and so that's going to be interesting.
Uh,
Joe still fixing them?
Mike arm.
I think we're back.
All right.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I got to get some better mind.
Go arms.
I liked that.
I liked the old ones.
We had better actually.
I've been watching the guests use it.
It's not an arm,
it's just kind of like a pacing.
That noise.
Um,
the best way is really to
have them stationary and you
just make the guy come up
to it.
Yeah.
You know,
Corolla has it set up where he's got,
um,
a straight arm and it's
screwed into the table.
There's a straight arm.
You can move it left or right,
but that's it.
Right.
That's really the best.
This,
this fucking thing is moving around.
Too much content on it.
But it's back.
But this seems so cool to
have this mechanical arm it
cause it seems like we're
professionals.
We're playing,
we're playing radio,
radio.
Well we're on the radio.
Legit now if you don't know,
we're on Sirius satellite radio.
I don't know what channel it is.
Opie and Anthony Channel used to be two
a two I think or something like that.
The buyer's opie and Anthony Channel
now it's really not the virus anymore.
They finally wised up.
I mean ob open the Anthony's a fucking
huge radio station or a huge radio,
a shell.
And they had been calling it the
virus since the beginning for like,
what has it been like eight
years or something crazy.
How long have you been on serious?
Long time.
I was serious.
What's sent me a free subscription.
At least they don't even give you shit.
I don't give me that.
Don't care.
Nothing.
You don't get a God damn thing.
Did you hear them talk about Patrice
the other day on Opie and Anthony?
I didn't hear it,
but I heard about it through the Internet.
Uh,
from the board as sad.
Yeah.
Subvert or actually tweeted me about.
I was like,
wow.
Then I went and looked
online and he had a stroke.
You know,
we,
we talk about it all the time,
you know,
cause it's a,
it's a big thing in my head.
You kind of take care
of your fucking shell.
You've got to take care of your body.
You have to,
you gotta,
you know,
you could fuck around a little bit,
but God dammit,
overall you should really be kind of fit.
You should do your best to be kind of fit.
You'll have a better life.
You're really well.
If you eat healthy,
take care of yourself,
you'll have a better life.
But Theresa is always a big guy and he
also had a lot of health problems too.
He had diabetes,
which is just fucking,
just a huge drag,
you know?
And that,
I don't know what contributes to a stroke
that could have easily contributed to
it.
And some people that are
real healthy get die,
get strokes.
You know,
strokes.
Father had a stroke when he was 67 he
smoked every day and I struck at 67 and
then he had like a couple
heart attacks 10 years later.
But the stroke made him be like eight
normal guy to being with a cane.
He had to learn,
relearn how to walk again.
I nanny ever since he had that
stroke was pretty miserable.
That's all I remember him
being just bored and miserable.
Well I would imagine,
you know,
your shell becomes a prison,
you can't,
you can't fucking get around.
That's,
that's a drag man.
But there you are smoking,
smoking,
you know,
you know I'm more concerned about
is my mom's been getting crazy.
My mom gets moles removed all the
time cause they're cancerous moles.
Oh God.
And they found one the
other day and they're like,
this is really bad.
This is like,
we caught it early but this is like,
this is cancerous and it's like near your
or spine or something weird like that.
And it's,
and the crazy thing is,
it's like,
they're like,
all right,
so we're gonna schedule you,
you know,
December 14th to take it out.
And I'm like,
wait a second,
you just said it was cancer.
Shouldn't you get that out?
Like now?
Like who cares if it's a slow
growing cancer immediately,
especially because you know you
have cancer now you're freaking out.
Who knows if that's going to
accelerate the growth of the thing.
I think it's probably a
scheduling issue that probably,
you know,
an insurance issue and a bunch
of other different things.
But yeah,
a better,
she had a lot of money,
they'd probably get around immediately.
And my sister,
it's just got some moles
removed for cancer and,
and now I'm like,
wait,
I haven't been to the doctor ever.
And I got,
I shave.
I know.
I just,
I you just go all the time.
I'm not,
I hate doctors.
I don't have a family doctor anymore.
Our family dentist,
I grew up with like the same doctor my
whole life and then I just moved away and
now I just go to like urgent cares,
you know,
I don't want to have a relationship
with a doctor and too old for that.
Now when are you going back to Ohio again?
Yeah,
exactly.
What is UFC coming here to hemo.
You could,
um,
schedule it,
you know,
and the next time he done.
That's true.
Since you liked the guy,
as long as you're gonna to go here.
And you know,
I noticed also,
I talked about this always
on Thompson as podcasts.
We always talk,
have a dental update every week.
But I,
I noticed that dentists out here
also seem more like car car salesman.
Like they,
they're automatically trying to get you
to upgrade things when he'd go there.
Like the other day I went
to the dentist and they,
they,
they charged me for a fluoride treatment.
I'm like,
I just wanted to cleaning.
What's this fluoride treatment?
And she's like,
oh,
she didn't go through.
That's extra.
You know,
you can get it.
And I'm like,
no,
she just gave it to me and
I didn't ask for a fluoride,
but they were trying to
add things on like Monday,
you know,
like,
oh,
you got the extra warranty,
tried to sell me on braces,
braces,
bitch.
You know,
my front seats are straight,
but two,
that would be fucking awesome.
Can we get braces?
Get the metal on my
front teeth are perfect,
but my bottom teeth,
there's some bunching up,
pretty bad ass.
But he said it to me and I looked at it a,
I'm,
I go,
I'm a man.
I don't give a fuck of
my teeth are a little,
can I chew through me?
Right.
Yeah,
they're good.
Well,
it's not like they're all jacked.
No,
because they don't know.
You don't want to be like
that old person with the wing.
You don't feel,
you don't get extra teeth coming
in and it gets spread out more.
When a frank shamrock got braces,
the former UFC champion
and he needed braces,
he had some weird dental thing going
on where you had like double teeth.
Right.
You ever met people that have
like teeth that grow over teeth.
They're like a lot of weird shit going on.
Right.
So I don't,
I don't know what that's about,
but he needed braces,
if that makes sense.
Like I understand like you don't want
people to let go every time you smiled.
What the fuck is going on as well?
You know there's certain,
you know,
you start tweaking about extra teeth
and shit starts fucking with your head.
You're like,
I don't want to get rid of some of
these goddamn teeth and fix my face.
That makes sense.
But to just have a little bit of a
crooked tooth here and they're like,
come on bitch,
what are you worried about?
I never understood why there's like you
see those older people or whatever that
has that one funky tooth that shoots out
of their mouth and they were just like,
why don't you just at
least get that polled?
You know you're,
you're just holding onto like,
you know,
like bald people are holding onto that
and the last amount of hair and trying to
comb it over,
move it around the circle with a fuck.
If you get that shit,
take it.
There's right writer
took all his teeth out.
Oh God.
All of his teeth.
He just drank.
I think I've talked about this before.
He always drinks like mountain dew.
Like you drink like a 12 pack of mountain
dew a day and his teeth were so bad he
never went to the dentist
cause you're gonna you know,
whatever for whatever reason.
And they were like,
dude,
all your teeth are fucked.
And he's like,
ah,
just pull them all.
Oh my God.
Pull them all.
It would cause the food.
Well,
he has fake teeth now like ventures,
but you know it's like the,
the cost to fix it all was impossible.
You know.
Oh my God,
like $20,000 something like Oh my God.
So,
so he has like basically
like the whole denture thing,
like a plastic gum and
you stick it on with glue.
Like they have like the Polident shit.
You ever see those commercials were like,
look,
your dentures can stay even under water
and they'd take a glass and they blew
the fucking fake teeth to it
and they put it under water.
Drink your water and not worried
about your two falling out.
That's so dark man.
When you,
when you have your whole
mouth full of fake teeth,
that's dark.
Yeah.
I had a friend who had no teeth.
My friend Mal Vernon,
Tommy,
he had no fucking teeth for Vernon.
Tom Over at Tommy.
Yeah.
He was a pool hustler
from white plains for,
for Mount Vernon.
But you know,
he used to come by executive
billiards in white plains new year.
The a certain weird dog and the need,
you didn't them any teeth.
He had no teeth when he wanted
a good little Philemon Yoan.
And what I do is I put it in the blender,
puts a Philemon yawn in the blender so
that he could just fucking buzz it down
and then eat it.
Sort of like how I make my
smoothie with Kale and shit.
He would do that with steak.
He would buzz up steak in a blender and
then eat them like this poor fuck he's
got no goddamn teeth.
Yeah,
it was,
he had,
I met some crazy fucking
people in my pool hall days,
but he was one of the craziest,
really nice guy.
Great Pool Player,
but terrible organizer of his life.
And what he did was he would
work for a taxi dispatch and a,
he would work like ridiculous,
ridiculous hours,
get enough money together and
then go play pool with it.
And gamble is money.
I mean he has a guy that was probably
only making a few hundred bucks a week.
Right.
And he would,
you know,
regularly come in and you know,
gamble for a couple thousand bucks and
sometimes he would lose and when he would
lose,
then he would go into debt with what's
called a Shylock and want a Shylock is,
is uh,
essentially a gangster,
a,
a person who loans you money and
they learn you loan you cash when you
ordinarily can't get alone and they do
it at a ridiculous rates of interest and
you know,
you have to play pay points
and he would fucking,
he would go into debt with these guys,
owe them like fucking,
you know,
20 grand,
10 grand,
whatever the fuck it is.
And this poor guy would just disappear
for months and just work it off,
just disappear and then go
right back into the hole again.
Same thing,
come gum back and,
and get alone and [inaudible]
to get alone and play some,
a lot of people talking a little shit,
I'm going to come back and play some,
show him how to fucking do it.
You know,
they don't have good cue ball control
and he would like tell you why he was
going to win and control.
You knew,
you knew the chances are that
he's probably going to lose.
It was going to be the same fucking
thing over and over again eventually.
You know,
it's like you,
you're,
you're running,
you're always,
always behind.
You know,
the expression always
behind the eight ball.
It just fucking can't quite catch a break.
And I watched this guy
and I learned a lot.
You know,
you learn a lot from people that are out
of control in their life about what's
possible.
Like the justifications,
you know,
like when you see people addicted
to gambling or addicted to anything,
you know,
you can,
you can watch people with their
control of life slips away.
And it's fascinating to watch.
You know,
I never been around gamblers
until I started playing pool.
Do you know anybody that's a gambler?
I know card players and it's kind of sad
and depressing because it's all about
luck,
you know?
And then sometimes they're like on top
of the game and then other times you,
you just see them like are suffering.
Like they're fucking
selling shit and just,
well it's certainly
not totally about luck,
but luck plays a in that.
Yeah,
for the most part it plays a part.
You definitely,
when you have guys have equal skill,
then yeah,
luck certainly plays a part
when the game was at uno,
so it was mostly water
hooked on,
you know,
I'm like,
what?
Because Ari is a pretty successful at
poker and he does it through strategy and
his intellect and his discipline.
He's,
he's a good poker player,
man.
He makes money.
There was a lot of times where he's making
way more money playing poker than he
was doing comedy,
but I think that shit's kinda dried up to,
I think it's hard.
The Internet apparently just
festered infested with bots.
There was a guy who was a on one of
these a pool websites and he's a pretty
pretty knowledgeable dude and he was
talking about how it's useless to play
poker on these websites
because they're all there.
They're like,
when you get on a website,
you might be playing in
a room with five people,
but two of them might
be bots and that might,
they might be bots set forward by the,
um,
the,
the poker company and you can't beat them.
And they're,
they're computer programs.
They're running,
it's cheating,
you're cheating.
And they're essentially running up the
bents and making people bet more money
and Boston people.
And it's like,
maybe it could just be you and some of
the guy who doesn't know how to play
poker and you could
make some fucking money,
but no,
no,
no.
It's you and some other guy who doesn't
know how to play poker and bots.
You're not going to win fucking crazy man.
When you hear about shit like that.
And then those,
uh,
which guys got busted recently,
they've gotten a lot of big,
big trouble.
They,
oh Bruce.
Buffer money.
And there was a bunch of your time.
We'll all start put,
what is it?
The one that's always on people's backs,
right?
And what the fuck is it called?
Fuck what's which,
which do search poker scandal.
Full tilt,
full tilt poker.
Yeah.
Apparently these guys just,
they had a bunch of money that they
kept their like in a bank and these
motherfuckers are spent it.
They just,
they ripped off online players
to the tune of 444 million bucks.
Holy Shit.
That's amazing.
And these guys,
well there were poker players there.
This is who started it,
the Department of Justice
specifically named pros,
Howard Lederer and Chris Ferguson who
were the founders of the site back in 2004
in the scheme,
uh,
the amount of poker pros who are involved
with full tilt is hard to ignore.
So they don't know really how
many people were involved.
But these guys,
uh,
they,
they just made mad loot
stealing from people.
That's how the world of the Gambler,
the pool player,
poker player,
like the,
the,
the dice player people,
the world of the Gambler,
w just to the cold war with CD people
to try to make this legitimate like what
they're trying to do
now with all this crazy,
you know,
professional poker and shit that
didn't exist when I was in high school.
What,
what this is,
is like they're doing,
as they're cleaning up degenerates,
they're cleaning up,
degenerates and presenting
them to the American public.
But these are degenerates.
Even if they're,
they're really rich and
successful and at it,
at their core,
they're,
most of them were degenerate gamblers.
And those are,
those people are crazy.
Those people did not.
He Shit,
man.
There's a certain percentage of them
that are off their fucking rocker.
That's why they've wound up
as professional gamblers.
You know,
they're,
they're junkies for adrenaline and
craziness and their impulse people and are
people that are willing to
take ridiculous chances.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot of nuttiness to the
world of the professional gambler.
I've never been a gambler.
I never had that in me at all.
I can't,
I don't like making bets.
And once in a while in Vegas,
I'll do it.
Like I'll,
I'll,
I'll just,
cause I not,
I don't get to do that
ever unless I'm in Vegas.
So once in a while I would spend like,
you know,
like 100 bucks Max,
but not really.
It's a scary,
you never going to win.
You mean what?
You went a little bit here and there,
but God damn you can lose a fuckload.
Yeah,
the pool players fuck themselves.
When it came to gambling,
they uh,
there was only one time that the
casino put a line on a pool tournament.
It was the US Open.
And you know,
when a a casino puts a
line on a pool tournament,
uh,
essentially they're saying
this guy's the favorite.
This guy's the big underdog.
And the big underdog was like,
you know,
40 to one or where the fuck it was
was Mike Lebron and Mike Bronze.
A good player.
But he's not like the best
players like Earl Strickland,
Johnny Archer,
those are,
those are the guys that everybody
assumed were probably Mike Segal.
Those are the guys.
Everybody assumed we're going
to get to the top buddy hall.
Those are like the real names.
Well,
they all dumped to this
Michael Lebron guy.
They all went,
they all went to the fucking,
the gambling booth.
They bet all their money
on Michael Lebron to win.
And then everybody lost him.
Mike,
Lebron,
and they all went cleaned up and then the,
the casino was like,
you mother fuckers like you,
you fucking,
but,
and you know,
what can they say?
I mean you,
you,
you can't leave a cat in a room with
a mouse and expect him not to kill it.
It's just the way it is.
They're,
they're degenerates.
The things you can help
it to them first place,
you know,
at a good pool tournament and Seton home.
Back then it might've
been like seven grand.
It might've been like,
if it was a big tournament and my us open,
it's like 40 or 50 back.
Who knows?
If it was 20 or 30 whatever it was,
$30,000 is a big score,
but you're not short of winning.
If you're going up,
you're playing a pool tournament.
It's a double elimination tournament.
You lose once to Johnny Archer and
then another time to Earl Strickland.
You're out.
You can do that or you
just put all your money.
I'm like Lebron and everybody
gets together and say,
let's make a deal.
I'm not going to button.
I bet a dollar make 40 isn't
hard to fucking figure out folks.
It's pull our money.
We've got 1000 bucks,
we're going to make $42,000 right now.
Split that shit up.
No,
no,
no drama whatsoever.
Let's do it.
And so they all got together
and everybody bet on this guy.
And then the casinos never
gambled on pool again.
They were like,
well,
we're not stupid.
You know,
it's not like you can't,
it's not like basketball.
Whereas like you know,
there's a lot of money and winning.
It's not like boxing.
I don't know if there's any fighters
that are going to put money down on
themselves and then take a dive.
Maybe they would if it was the end of
their career and they can be assured that
they can make a lot of money.
That was always a big speculation about
Marvin because Marvin Hagler lost his
last fight to sugar ray Leonard,
where he was a big favorite to win that
fight and it didn't look like the same.
Marvin Hagler.
It didn't look like,
like when he got sugary against the ropes,
didn't look like it was
really punishing them.
It didn't really look like
he was trying to stop him.
It was almost like he knew that the fix
was in and he was a part of it because
after it was over,
I mean,
and I'm just,
look,
Marvin Hagler is one of the
greatest boxers of all time.
I'm not implying,
I'm just going with the urban legend.
After it was over,
he leaves and goes to
Italy and makes movies.
He becomes an Italian
movie star just leaves.
So like if he made some
sort of a deal with the mob
and they're like,
listen,
this is what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to bet a lot of
money on a sugar ray Leonard.
You will knock,
knock 'em out and you leave them alone.
The judges are in the bucket to
going to make a lot of money.
Come to Italy.
[inaudible] star.
Fuck this box saying you want
to be a movie star in Italy.
So they taught them Italian,
flew him out to Italy.
He would give him a fucking movie star.
It's that's those,
the urban,
that's the urban legend.
The reality is one of the
greatest boxers of all time.
Marvin Hagler,
huge Marvin Hagler Fan.
He was a monster man.
I remember when I was a kid,
I watched him,
he was training from a staff of ham show
and they had him on the news cause he
was,
he was,
what he would do is on the Cape,
he would live on Cape Cod,
which is the ocean that
nobody went to in the winter.
God was fucking frigid,
you know,
it's zero degrees and the waves would be
crashing and the wind would be whipping
in the fucking windshield factor was like,
who knows how many fucking degrees below
zero and this motherfucker would be
running on the beach screaming war.
You know Marvin Hagler like I remember
watching it on TV when I was a little kid
going,
Holy Shit,
look at this guy.
Like that was in my mind,
like that's what a fighter could be.
Like.
The scariest fighter would be a fighter
that's doing everything correctly.
100% focus,
100% dedicated,
stays away from his wife,
doesn't go anywhere near as kids,
locks himself in a fucking house on the
beach and just works out every day and
runs on the beach and just wants
to kill you and can't wait.
And it's counting the days down for he
gets to punch you in the fucking face,
you know?
So I'm not saying that
Marvin Hagler took a dive,
but I'm saying that that's the rumor.
This is going to be a fun UFC man.
You gotta start,
when's the next year?
I've said you're going to come to,
you want to come to San Jose?
San Jose.
We've got some shows there too.
We're doing a,
when is that?
During the San Jose Improv.
When is that?
Do you know what number?
Uh,
cause it on my little calendar,
I guess November 18th,
we're going to be at
the San Jose and Improv.
It's a Joey Diaz is coming now.
We just found out that
Brian is coming as well.
I Dunno who else to come in.
We might have one other comic con,
maybe Dunkin or whoever's around.
And,
uh,
then we got the,
the two shows at the,
um,
at the San Jose Improv that night.
And then the UFC is the
next night and it's a,
it's a killer.
UFC too.
It's Vandelay Silva versus Conley
and Shogun versus Henderson.
It's got a nice fucking nuts.
That's a good one.
God,
I hope nobody gets hurt
before that one comes.
I get right.
It kind of sucks.
That was sports crazy.
You know,
when you're,
when you got to practice kicking the
shit out of each other and punching each
other and need each other
in the face and Shit,
man,
people get hurt.
You know,
you tweaked knees.
Look,
even George Saint Pierre,
man George has never pulled
out with a knee injury before.
I mean,
I think he's hurt himself in the past.
I can't remember him pulling out
a fight cell because he was hurt.
Maybe I'm wrong.
I know he,
uh,
he,
he has been injured like
after he fought Tiago Alvarez.
He,
he was laid up for a while because he
fucked as growing up in that fight.
But I can't remember other injuries
where he had to pull out of a fight.
I might be wrong though.
So many guys do.
It's just no way around it man.
And I hate it.
But it's a smart thing to do.
You got to pull out,
you can't fight injured,
you know you fight injured,
you get fucked up,
you fight Carlos condit and
you only got one wing do.
You might get jacked.
That guy's a beast if you can barely,
you know you can't move right.
And if you get hurts,
if it gets hurt more like during the
fight and you like try to dig in on it and
move a certain direction,
maybe you can't move and you get hit with
a kick you would've never got hit with
and then it's lights out and
then your whole career changes.
Your whole life changes.
Like at that level of
the game you can't do it.
But I seen dudes fight hurt before Mike
[inaudible] was the biggest example.
He's a real tough guy.
And he came into the UFC once,
he fought a CBD Holloway and he came in
with his whole leg taped up like a cast.
It was fucking nuts.
Like Soccer Raba style.
Have you ever saw Sakuraba
back in the old pride days?
Sakharova was amazing fighter,
but his knees were fucked up.
He just had been leg locked too
many times and kick too many times.
They were just badly damaged
so bad that he would get these,
his legs taped up before
the fights and it was nuts.
It was like a mummy.
I mean it was like he was like from
halfway down to is the the to his calf all
the way up to like a foot above his knee.
It was all taped up.
It was like crazy.
But he had to do that and he
would like walk like an old man,
you know,
you had to do that and then you'd go
in and kick you with that same leg.
Fucking he like stabilize his own knees
with tape and raps because it was like
old loose and fucked up.
You know,
it was really one of the
reasons why people loved him.
They knew he's all battered up and he
was still going there and go fucking
crazy.
But it's really not smart.
It's really not smart to fight injury,
you know?
And you're supposed to,
if you like,
you look at a guy like
George Saint Pierre,
he does everything perfectly.
It's very technical and he
wants to always be able to,
you know,
avoid getting hit but hit the other guy.
He wants to always be able to
utilize the right strategy.
And if you got a fucked up wheel man,
if your knee is jack,
that's like,
that's a good percent of his whole game.
So game is about exploding on people
and getting out of the way of people and
making sure people can't take them down
and making sure he can take them down
and then kicking them.
You know,
there's,
that's his whole game kicking and
punching him and taking him down and like,
fuck you can't kick somebody.
You can't,
you can't run out of the way.
you know?
That's a terrifying thing
for a fighter to have.
Only one need at works.
What a fucking Dudee sport,
dude.
You take your body and you try to
blast someone else's body with it.
No thanks.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
You get exhausted,
you know,
and everybody's just trying to figure
out the right way to do it and no one's
quite got it mastered yet.
They've only got it mastered against this
level and we're always looking at the
next level coming up.
Like even though Anderson Silva is,
no doubt about it,
the greatest fighter that ever
walked the face of the earth,
there's nobody that's ever been better.
No one has ever done the kind
of shit that that guy does.
I'll give you look at his fight,
his last fight that he had.
Man,
you should know Cami is a beast.
He's a tough,
tough fucking guy.
No one's ever handled him
the way Anderson handled him.
Anderson is just on this complete
total different new level.
But to some people coming up,
man,
they're coming up and they're,
they're going to be better.
There's the John Jones is of the world.
You know,
you look at John Jones go,
what's John Jones going to be like when
he's 30 John Johnson's like 23 years old
dude,
and he's way better at 23 then he was
at 22 I met him at 22 he was good then.
He's fucking way better now.
What's going to be like
and he's 25 what's eating?
Even like when he's 28 years old,
he's going to be a fucking
comic book Superhero Dude.
He's just going to be
doing shit to people.
You can't even believe some young guy,
people that are coming up
that aren't that talented.
People that have physical flaws,
people that have flaws and their game,
he's just going to run through them.
Just gonna run through them.
The question is,
when does the,
the two paths cross like the master,
like Anderson Silva,
who's a master at a certain few levels
of the game and then this young kid
coming up who slowly mastering everything,
you know,
comes from this completely
different discipline of wrestling.
You know,
Anderson comes from
this Moitai discipline.
His,
his discipline is all about kicking you
and punching and all of sudden there's
this wrestler who's kicking
and punching you and he's like,
what?
He can wrestle too.
And he's developing this ridiculous
kicking and punching game.
Fuck,
that's the next level.
And then there's going
to be someone after him,
man.
There's to be some guy who does everything
twice as fast as everybody else does
it.
And he's coming up right now.
He's probably 10 years old right now.
And what's holding the pads for him?
It was probably more fighters now in
training than there's ever been ever been
by far.
And it's,
the organizations are growing,
you know,
people always say that the UFC is a,
um,
is a,
a monopoly,
you know,
and the,
they're,
they're actually even being
investigated by someone from federal,
federal,
cc,
federal trade,
FTC federal trade commission,
and they're being investigated
as being a monopoly,
but it's not a monopoly.
They just do it better than anybody else.
It's like you can't,
you can't say that Nascar is a monopoly,
but if you wanted to say,
hey,
let's start up our own fucking car league.
You know we're going to just
race cars all across the country.
What are you going to call it?
The new car league.
Everybody like,
but it's not Nascar,
right?
No.
Well now it's not.
Nascar has a monopoly.
Just they're the best at it.
You could start your own
car league if you want to.
That's the same thing with the UFC.
The UFC is not a monopoly.
You know,
they just have the best fighters right
now cause they have the most money and
the most popularity,
but they built this shit up man.
If you want to do it by yourself,
do it by herself and Bella
tours doing it by themselves.
There's a company called [inaudible].
They're fucking,
they've got some good fighters,
man.
They've got a good show.
They got this Guy Jimmy Smith
who does the commentary.
He's really good at it.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu,
knows what the fuck is going on.
He's gives excellent commentary there.
Color guys,
really good.
They have a good show.
They do a different format where they
have tournament's and they hold this
tournament and the tournament takes place
over several weeks or several months
rather.
And then they pick a guy who wins a
tournament and he fights for the title and
you know,
they do a fucking real good job man.
And they do a real good job with it
and they just got bought out by Viacom.
So it's not that the UFC is a monopoly,
there's other people in the game.
They just been in the game longer.
They spent more money,
they invested more time,
they do it better.
It's that simple.
You know,
it's like there's a certain amount of
people that whenever you get to a certain
level of success,
they want to,
they want to think that you did
something wrong to get there.
But if it wasn't for the UFC,
man,
nobody would have invested
that kind of money.
Eventually.
I think MMA would have slowly broken
through to the mainstream over the course
of who knows how many years.
Or it could have wound up like soccer
where everybody thought it was going to
make it,
but it never,
did you remember?
Well,
soccer when we were kids,
they're pushing soccer.
Like soccer is eventually going
to be a big professional sport.
I remember that,
but it never did.
It just never quite marketed it correctly.
It never quite got through.
Yeah,
and same with hockey for Columbus.
He's still pretty good
for Ohio at four I lived,
they tried to push hockey a lot.
Yeah,
it was pretty big for a while,
but now it's kind of like,
I don't think it's,
if someone smart,
if someone's got balls,
listen to me right now.
This is the thing.
K One kickboxing.
Kickboxing is some of the most
exciting shit to watch in the world.
If you watch the highest level kickboxers
God damn is that should exciting.
It's so fucking fun to watch.
They go at it,
man.
It's only three rounds.
Even title fights are like three rounds.
They fucking go to a war man.
And those,
some of the fights are
five rounds I think.
But either way they,
they're,
they're fun and it's all striking,
which is what a lot of people like a
lot of people don't like the wrestling
aspect of MMA.
I love it because I think it's the
most realistic sport in the world.
I mean it is real fighting.
It's a sport of real fighting
encompassing all the different techniques.
So to me it's more complicated.
It's more cerebral.
There's more strategy involved
because there's more variables.
I,
I'm always going to be a
huge fan of primarily of MMA.
If I had one thing to
watch it would be MMA,
but I love fucking kickboxing too.
I love watching it.
It's so much more exciting than regular
boxing and we know how boxing is still
doing well.
People still want to
see a good boxing match.
You know,
if Manny Pacquiao was fighting,
people are still going to pack in
to see that guy light people up.
But man,
if you watch some high level kickboxing,
boxing becomes boring
because they can't kick,
they're not doing all
this other crazy shit.
You Watch.
Like I went to the um,
morning time professional league.
They had a show at long beach and I
went down and check that shit out.
God Damn,
it was fun,
Dude.
There was some of the best kickboxers
in the world and just I was in the front
row and watching these guys go at it,
man.
Why Old Wild Shit?
Because they don't have to
worry about being taken down.
There's no takedowns so they're just
fucking t and off on each other.
Mad Wild head kick knockouts and spinning
back fist knockouts and cotton people
with elbows.
It was nuts,
man.
It's a,
it's a crazy sport.
I can't believe that.
It doesn't get the press that it deserves
because like maybe it's not as good as
MMA,
but God damn if it ain't a close
second and it's not being promoted,
someone's,
someone's completely dropped the ball,
you know,
they owe the people own k
one they owe a lot of money,
man.
They want to start fights,
but they want to not have to pay all
the fighters that they owe money to and
they,
oh,
just fucking untold millions of dollars
to fighters if they haven't paid.
So they're in a bad financial situation,
but it's because they're just,
they've didn't promote it correctly.
If somebody liked the UFC,
came along,
if zoo for came along and picked up k one,
they're not interested in it.
I've talked to them about it.
But if someone like that did,
if Mark Cuban did or someone
with balls and a lot of money,
who loves the sport?
God Damn,
that's a gold mine.
It's a Goddamn gold mine.
Mark Cuban.
Go do it.
You already got Michael
Chavela working for you.
Michael Chevelle,
the Australian guy and my buddy.
You've toned out.
You've completely zoned out.
Which talking about finding,
what are you doing?
You're online.
You're checking your Facebook.
No,
I was looking at trying to find
something on Monday to talk about,
but I can't find it.
What was it?
Uh,
the,
I don't want to talk about it.
You don't want it because
I want to find it.
If I talk about it cause
it's kind of pointless.
Well,
why don't you help me
tell me and I'll help you.
Oh,
there's a,
something about the anonymous,
uh,
it's a anonymous website
that I wanted to do show you,
but,
and an anonymous website they have.
Yeah.
No,
I don't know if it's them or not.
I can't tell if it's real or not,
but it's pointless not mine.
So dare you Brian Up Darren.
So,
um,
this weekend,
Friday,
today's Thursday,
tomorrow night you got to show at
the Ice House and when will the uh,
ice,
the ice house podcast studios confirmed,
right?
Yeah,
I live in the next week or two.
So I'm leaving all deaf squad over
there and then we're still going to do a
podcast tomorrow though
with Duncan Trussell.
Okay,
beautiful.
Yeah.
And uh,
you're going to do a podcast from the ice
house and are you going to have it set
up with Mike?
So we're going to do it like old school,
like we did hold still and then
once we get the studio there,
then we're probably going to make that
a whole like night at the ice house or
something like that.
Well,
people were saying that
the last one was good,
but it felt like I was
pocket calling everybody.
Like that's what it was like.
It was like they're tuned into a
conversation that you can barely hear.
You could hear everything else in the
background and people really liked the
fact that we were sitting there at a
desk right in front of the door to the
club.
People were getting a kick out of that,
like as the show was going on,
like people who are podcast
fans like holy shit,
they're podcasting right there.
And it was really kind of cool,
you know?
Yeah.
If we had that area,
I would like to have eventually a,
an area set up where we could do it like
maybe before the shows and in between
shows and doing the back room and
the while the show's going on.
We could do it right there,
do it right there,
that table.
But we
would have to have it a little more
soundproof than it is just a wee bit,
you know,
just like a curtain or
something like that.
It would be cool if people
knew we were right there.
But if,
if you hear it,
it's,
it's all the talking and shit.
It's like a really bleeds
into the microphone.
It makes it hard to listen to.
They were talking about eventually I,
there's another office that
depending on how all this goes,
how they were thinking about building a
like a window so we could actually watch
who's on stage while we're podcasting
behind the audience and then we can have
like little inner if so we
can hear it would be amazing.
And you know what else we can do that
I think we should probably fuck around
with a little bit is occasionally
have shows live on stage,
have a podcast,
live on stage a Jim Norton.
Yeah,
because it's a small room
because it's only 85 seats.
It's so intimate that it doesn't feel
like the conversation is completely out of
line.
I just think that it,
exactly how it felt last time and
though even if there's like a couple of
strangers in the room,
we were kind of not being ourself.
We're kind of almost playing,
playing it up.
I remember feeling that like,
like,
like it felt like we were
doing bits almost or at least,
you know,
kind of,
yeah.
Well Norton is such a great performer.
We know we did it with him,
was the perfect guy to do it with in
front of an audience cause he's just
immediately went into attack mode and
it was just killing like right off the
bat.
And then,
um,
you know,
I think it's settled in after a while
and it became intimate when I became
intimate also was when it was real
obvious that everybody in the show in the
audience was a podcast fan.
And so that was fun for them to
be able to sit in and watch it.
And even though we only did it once,
I wouldn't be adverse to doing it again.
And I also liked the idea that we could
hand out the microphone and we hung out,
pass out microphones to the crowd and
then the crowd would ask questions.
That was a fun thing that,
that little kind of a more
relaxed question and answer
cause I kind of stopped
doing that.
Uh,
rarely do that.
with an audience.
I think I did at one time last week.
And you're like,
oh,
you do the Q and.
A.
You know,
cause I haven't been really
doing it because it leads
to like a weird ending for
a show.
Like sometimes it's kind
of like you're going up,
this is like a great finale of an ending.
And then it's like,
all right,
now let's go backwards and
just kind of talk continental.
Yeah.
It's Kinda weird.
It's weird.
And then people would always
ask me questions that weren't,
that really didn't lead themselves into
being funny to me about Margaret Court
are know fighters.
Yeah.
It couldn't be,
there was a random fighter thing
and then there was always like it.
Occasionally people would,
well not occasionally,
every time people would
want to talk about drugs,
somebody would always
yell a damn dude too,
you know,
fucking to me.
But mushrooms,
it's at a certain point in time you can
only explain psychedelic experiences so
many times before you start
becoming a character of your shelf.
You know,
you're like,
what am I,
how am I going to explain DMT?
The thousandth time?
I can't.
I'm going to give you
some and you to smoke it.
And that's the only
way it's going to work.
And I don't have any,
so good luck.
It's like go.
You know,
you can't,
people always say that
a man like on Twitter,
please follow me and DMA.
I need to talk to you about DMT.
Guess what?
No you don't.
You don't need to talk
to me about some illegal drug.
I don't know you skippy.
You could be anybody.
It could be some fucking Weirdo.
You'd be a cop.
You can be crazy person.
You don't need to talk to me about DMT,
right when it comes to legal.
Yes,
it becomes league.
I'll talk to everybody.
I'll,
I'll hold a seminar on
the fucking White House.
Front steps.
I'll tell people about it.
Yeah.
Tell you how to take three
deep hits until that time.
I'm not saying shit.
That's the next war.
The war for consciousness.
The warfare control of he should be legal.
Um,
I think,
and I've said this many times before,
that we need schamens that if you're
going to have something like mushrooms,
if you're going to have
something like pay Payoti,
what you need is a,
a very,
uh,
rigorous,
sort of a ritual and a path to follow
in order to have these experiences.
I don't think they should
just be open for recreation.
I think too many people doom and fuck
their head up and don't know what they're
doing and they can be so beneficial.
And I'm not saying that
if you're a grown man,
you shouldn't.
Once you have experienced in these realms,
you shouldn't be able to get together
with your friends and have a few mushrooms
and hang out and be silly and laugh.
I absolutely think you should be able to,
you should be able to,
like,
there's a lot of people that are like
real serious about it and so you should
only do it for shamonic rituals
and never do it or for recreation.
And I'm like,
why?
Why,
when it can be fun to
do it for recreation.
They don't,
don't say you have to do it one way
or another or that it's disrespectful.
Guess what?
The mushroom doesn't give a fuck
about your respect in this world.
The,
the,
the mushroom is,
is a,
is whatever it is,
whatever that experience is,
it seems to be about
forgiveness and love and fun.
You know,
that's what it seems to be about reality
and truth and forgiveness and love and
fun.
And I don't think it minds
if you use a casually,
but I think we need to have
some sort of a setup where,
uh,
people are educated on it.
People like you don't just dive into
it not knowing what the fuck it is.
You W we could easily
have a service where,
you know,
if it was legal,
you could set up these shamonic
places where someone could go and you,
this is Tom and Tom's going to
guide you through the program.
Today's going to be the
first day and today,
essentially what we're going
to do is we're gonna sit down,
we're going to watch a documentary.
We're going to have a question to answer.
We're going to watch a documentary about
the history of use of mushrooms in the
world.
And then you'll fucking see this
documentary on Gordon Wasson and all these
other people that took mushrooms and what
these tribes learned about it and how
this was suppressed by,
you know,
the various fucking dictators and kings.
And it'll go through the history of it.
And then the next day you
go through the history of,
uh,
you know,
other psychedelic drugs and you know,
what's the benefit of them and what's
the dangers of them and how does it
interact with your body and how
can we find out if you know you're,
you're,
you know,
especially vulnerable,
and then slowly but surely you
introduce someone into those,
those realms.
And I suggest starting
them off really lightly.
I think that the first mushroom
experience you should have,
it should be fairly high.
You should just just
get a little bit of it.
So you just kind of get a feel of it
and a little giggle and yourself system
where you don't feel scared,
you don't feel nervous,
you just go,
oh,
this is all right.
This is,
this is this crazy experience.
This is just weird.
Wow,
this is wild.
What a weird way of looking at the world
I have now and then eventually slowly
but surely you should be introduced into
the deeper and deeper dimensions into
the ideas that there is no real solid
line between this world and the others.
It's just that this is
all that we can detect.
This is all that we have the equipment
to see and that what what mushrooms do,
any of these psychedelic drugs do is
chemically alter the way your frequency or
the way your brain interacts with the
universe and allows you to see some shit
that might just be there all the time.
He just might not have
the ability to see it.
That's what I think.
I think all of it should be legal.
There's no way one person should be
keeping you from these experiences.
What should be illegal and especially
illegal to sell as anything that you think
to damage people or harm people or
cause addiction and that shit already is
legal.
That shit has already been sold
by pharmaceutical companies.
Things that are far,
far,
far more dangerous.
You know,
even when you come into like
drugs that are dangerous,
like heroin,
you know what the fucking cure for heroin
is or what they give you and you're
hooked on heroin.
They give you methadone,
man,
which in many people's eyes is
way worse than heroin itself.
More addictive than heroin itself.
Hard to get off.
It's fucking dangerous shit.
It's all gross,
you know?
So I think that stuff that's
bad for you as a society,
we should shun and that's
what smart people would do.
That's what educated people would do.
What people that are in just this fucking
whirlwind of momentum and hysteria,
that's not based on anything
logical or rational or or realistic.
That's when the world is like that.
That's when you get drug
laws like we have right now.
Nutty ones don't make any
sense or not based on logic.
They're not based on knowledge.
They're based on some bullshit that was
taught in the 1930s there based on some
sweeping drug addicts,
drug acts that which included things that
weren't even psychoactive in humans in
1970 so that's what I think.
We're fucking being oppressed.
No question about it.
We have a system that's old as fuck
and you're seeing it right now with his
craziest,
there's these demonstration and
the occupy Wall Street movement.
That's the financial system.
That system is old as fuck.
We also have a legal
system that's old as fuck.
It's stupid and that gets ridiculous
and thinks that it's above the humans,
that it's supposed to be there to
help and aid and assist and instead of
assisting the humans that it's that,
that you know,
it's supposed to be there to protect.
Instead they act as a fucking bully unit
for big businesses that seek to push
things in one way or another
in order to make more money.
W,
w the whole thing is just filled with
clients across the board with the legal
system,
the financial system,
and the fact that things
like marijuana and mushrooms,
things that probably aided in people's
perception and the evolution of people's
perception since there were
people from the very beginning.
I know for a fact that those things have
helped me and I know for a fact they've
helped you and everybody that we know
that's had psychedelic experiences has
been helped by them.
You know,
we know people that have had bad ones.
We know people that have bet scary ones,
but when you sit down with them and say,
what did you learn?
What did you get out of that?
They almost all say humility.
They almost all say a
feeling of connectedness.
Member Ari.
Ari was like an angry dude for a while
until Ari started tripping and when Ari
started tripping,
dude,
he started doing mushrooms
like fairly regularly.
Every few months or so are
you became a way nicer guy,
a way more aware of the fact that
he should be a nice guy there.
Therefore,
you man,
this message brought to you by mushrooms
and the marijuana shrunk to things that
are illegal to things early on.
This fucking wacky world.
We live in Brian Reichel.
We know it's not illegal
podcasts pitches next week.
Joe Diaz on Monday,
supposedly David Tail on Tuesday.
I got to Holler at Homie and we got to
work this out and we're going to try to
get Shane from uh,
vice TV,
which should be absolutely
fucking spectacular.
And um,
Friday which is tomorrow
night at the Ice House.
Gimme the lineup.
Uh,
we got Duncan Trussell,
our magical Steve run is easy.
Kevin Christie,
Sam Tripoli.
It's his birthday too and Jason
Tebow and it's $15 on sale right now.
Last week sold out.
It's,
you can't,
I mean usually that,
that would be just one of those guys too.
Those guys are headliners.
That would be like a $30 show usually.
So
yeah,
that's a great shot.
It's a great show with
a bunch of great guys.
And if you never seen Tripoli or nursing
Dunkin or any of those guys that's top
notch,
stand up in La and it's
only like 15 bucks,
15 bucks,
and they're going to be
doing podcasts there.
So if you fucking get in on that,
they might let you go.
Hi Mom.
I'm going to say no,
no
that have people come in and we
won't tell them where the studio is.
That's the thing.
Eventually the studio
will have to be in glass,
so it'd be going to put,
put their boogers on it and shit,
but just get some really
thick glass like plexiglass,
some bulletproof shit.
So we could do it right in
front of people like the zoo.
Yeah,
that'd be awesome.
That'd be awesome to have it
like right set up there were,
how about that,
you know that little door to the,
to the ice house when you
go into that small room.
How about if that wall was just all
plexiglass and you right where the ticket
booth is right next to it.
We had like microphone
setup and we did it like,
so you could see right
when you're on stage.
Yeah.
And we have the,
there's a little change machines where
you usually get the zoo where you could
feed the animals,
but it'd be like skittles and
stuff and they can give us candy.
Hmm.
Maybe they give you
candy if you get laughs,
right.
Maybe if,
if you see a little,
yeah.
Like
it has to like the,
the decibel level of the laughter has to
reach a certain level and then a green
light goes off in a little skittle and
goes into a tray or joint or joint.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
Once again,
we've been in business with
those guys for a long time now.
It's been a very fun and uh,
it's funny.
It makes me take things less seriously
because what are you looking for it?
I'm just finding it because,
um,
oh,
the blue one because I don't know,
man.
There's something ridiculous
being sponsored by a rubber
pussy and I think it's
good for us to be taken less seriously,
which is why you're here.
And,
uh,
anyway,
what I really,
Shane Smith contact me.
We're going to make this happen.
I'm so excited about that
either next week or soon.
And um,
all right.
That's it.
You fucking freaks.
Thanks to the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link.
Enter in the code name,
Rogan.
Get your 15% off.
Somebody says,
I shouldn't say enter in
cause enter means to put in,
but fuck you.
How about that grammar people swat bag.
Uh,
I say that with all the love in the world.
Also,
we're sponsored by on
it on it.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and also
this new stuff called new mood.
It's five HTP and some other groovy
shit that makes you feel better.
And also we have a shroom tech,
which is an athletic supplement for elite
athletes based on the courthouse steps
mushroom that I have been using lately.
And I find fucking excellent.
It's all good shit.
You freaks.
Thanks for everything.
Thanks for making this
podcast so successful.
Thanks for being cool as fuck.
Thanks for every time I go out
of comedy clubs and theaters.
I hear from wait staff all the time that
you guys are the coolest motherfuckers
they ever get to wait on.
Um,
I,
I this no bullshit.
We all here,
they were saying that at the
meeting I had at the Ice House,
how you guys are your fans all
drink and tip and that it's huge.
They're nice people.
You know,
I think you put that out there,
man.
You put that out there and
people gravitate towards it.
And I think this podcast,
you know,
reinforces that and we
need people to think,
to hear that you're supposed to
think a certain way that it's,
it's a good way to think.
You know,
I heard that thing you did with
Siri where you ask Siri that,
what is the meaning of life?
Did you see the Brody Stevens thing?
Yeah.
That was beautiful.
You know,
it's crazy in every told you
a really good series said,
be nice to people.
Go for walks and what's good.
What was crazy is your fellow man,
Brody was just like,
right before that happened.
Brody goes,
Brian,
do you walk?
I'm like,
no.
And he goes,
you need to go on walks.
You need to read books.
He had a book.
He's like,
I'm reading the secrets.
I just make sure you read this.
And he's like,
don't eat fat foods.
Like he was giving me this
whole lecture and I'm like,
let's see what series it has to
say about the meaning of life.
And I played,
it was exactly what Brody said.
It gave me shivers like in the video,
like you can watch the video on Vimeo.
I have like goosebumps and
we're all freaking the fuck out.
Maybe Brody Stevens now these on heavy
meds is tapping into the true meaning of
the universe.
Maybe he's got the answers.
Do we need to have Brody
Stevens on this podcast?
Yeah,
we need to go on his podcast.
How about that?
But that squad studious,
I will come to death squads,
studios in Pasadena and tomorrow night
get your tickets because it will sell
out.
There's only 85 seats in this place.
Two shows,
eight and 10 30 is that what it does?
Uh,
eight and 10,
I think
eight and 10.
And we'll see you guys on Monday.
And as always,
we love you bitches,
you know,
we loved it.